[Musique]
Julia Cager, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors, je m'appelle Julia Cager, j'ai 36
ans, je suis professeur d'économie. Euh
je travaille beaucoup sur toutes les
questions de financement de de la
démocratie, de financement des médias.
Euh je suis aussi présidente de
l'association Un bout du monde qui veut
faire des des citoyens euh et des
journalistes les actionnaires de leur
médias.
Vous êtes passé par Harvard ?
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez fait là-bas ?
J'ai fait une testse d'économie là-bas.
Je tiens à dire que j'ai fait une testse
d'économie à Harvard financée
entièrement par Harvard. Donc uniquement
avec une bourse.
Pourquoi vous précisez ça ? Bah non,
parce que quand on dit au revoir tout de
suite, ça fait un peu euh fils à papa,
non ?
Il se trouve que moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir mes études financées bah d'abord
par l'État français des 21 ans et puis
ensuite par du coup le les fac
américaines. Donc j'ai fait que des
études gratuites. J'ai j'ai un souvenir
qui est qui est très bizarre mais qui
m'avait beaucoup beaucoup
finalement marqué à une certaine époque
où je rentrais aux États-Unis donc avec
avec mon visa.
J'allais pour une conférence et le type
à la à la douane américaine regarde, il
me dit donc vous venez pourquoi ? que
j'explique que je viens que je fais mes
études là-bas. Il m'avait dit comme ça
en anglais ah pauvre petite fille riche.
Et ça m'avait vraiment traumatisé parce
que je voulais vraiment lui dire mais
quoi ? Pas du tout quoi. C'est pas parce
que c'est marqué Harvard sur ma carte
que enfin qu'il y a pas un côté méritant
ou que et en même temps je pense que je
peux comprendre d'une certaine manière
sa sa colère mais c'est c'était ça
m'avait heurté frontalement.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler des médias, on
va parler d'économie, on va parler tout
un tas de choses.
On se on se retrouve dans un milieu et
dans un climat médiatique qui est très
tendu. Est-ce que vous pouvez me donner
votre analyse du biotop médiatique ?
Bah, je pense que ce qui me frappe le
plus aujourd'hui, c'est c'est la
défiance dans les médias. Euh vous avez
moins d'un/art des Français qui qui ont
confiance dans les médias. c'est on se
rend pas compte, ça veut dire qu'il y a
3/4 des citoyens qui consomment de
l'info sans avoir confiance dans l'info
qu'il qu'il consomme. Et l'autre truc
dont on se rend pas compte, c'est c'est
les raisons pour lesquelles c'est le
cas. Et les raisons pour lesquelles
c'est le cas, c'est qu'on a une
surconcentration du secteur médiatique
entre un tout petit nombre de mains
d'actionnaires, d'actionnaires
industriels qui viennent d'un secteur
qui est pas celui des médias. Et
finalement, on est rentré dans cette
espèce d'équilibre comme s'il y avait
pas d'autres équilibres possibles,
d'autres modèles alternatifs et on se
satisfait d'un système où euh on
consomme de l'info sous perfusion de de
mes scèes d'une part et puis d'autre
part bah la plupart des citoyens font
pas confiance euh aux médias qui
consomment. Et en plus de ça et c'est ça
qui me frappe vraiment le le plus et
c'est aussi pour ça que du coup on a on
a créé l'association un bout du monde
euh c'est qu'on a des actionnaires qui
passent leur temps à taper sur leur
journaliste finalement comme si rien ne
pouvait être fait. Donc si je prends là
juste lecture récente de la semaine
dernière à ScienceVi qui était un
magazine qui appartenait au groupe
Mondadori qui a été racheté par Re Media
l'an dernier, vous avez l'actionnaire
qui a décidé finalement de séparer
entièrement la rédaction papier de la
rédaction web et qui se met à publier
n'importe quoi sur le web. Des fake
news, des articles faux. Si si du
copiercollé, des fake news, des articles
faux, des articles en contradiction
complète avec ce qui est dans le papier.
Vos sources pour les fake news.
Ah bah pour le coup science vie, c'est
assez drôle. Vous regardez le magazine
papier et vous regardez le site
internet. Là on vous pouvez y aller en
direct. Vous aviez un énorme truc, une
vidéo sur une nouvelle comète qui vient
de de frôer la la la terre. Enf que des
informations complètement complètement
fake qui sont fait par un producteur de
contenu, plus par un journaliste. Et là,
vous avez les journalistes qui vont dire
à leurs actionnaires, "Attendez, c'est
pas possible, on est une marque
scienvie, on fait notre travail, on est
des journalistes, donc vous pouvez pas
mettre sur le site internet absolument
n'importe quoi." Et là, l'actionnaire
dit, "On fait ce qu'on veut." C'est nous
l'actionnaire, c'est nous qui possédons
la marque.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable tout de
suite au bout des premières minutes. Je
me mets à la place du philanthrope
Messen qui rachète le média. Si si le
canard perd du pognon.
Ouais, mais c'est pas le cas pour
scienfie. C'est pas le cas. Alors, rewor
c'est tout sauf un philanthropeen.
C'est une boîte qui est côteur en bourse
pour commencer. Euh donc, c'est une
boîte qui a racheté les magazines du
groupe Mondadori pour faire des profits.
C'est pour ça qu'il les ont racheté.
Vous êtes sûr et certain que
Ah oui oui oui. Allez voir allez voir
sur le site. La bonne nouvelle c'est que
c'est pas compliqué à les trouver
puisqu'ils en mettent vraiment beaucoup.
Et en plus Science Sville, c'est un
magazine qui gagne de l'argent sauf que
pour Rewor, ils en gagnent pas assez.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font ? Bah ils
diminuent les charges. Vous diminuez les
charges, vous faites partir les
journalistes au fur et à mesure. Il y en
a qui sont partis au moment du rachat.
Il les pousse tous, il pousse la
rédaction vers la sortie et vous
profitez de la marque parce qu'il y a
encore plein de gens qui finalement sont
habitués à sciences vi vont continuer à
s'abonner pendant un pendant un certain
nombre d'années. Donc vous allez dégager
des marges bénéficiaires grâce à ça euh
en produisant pour le coup du fake de la
mauvaise qualité en ligne. Vous allez
tuer un média mais vous vous en moquez
parce que dans 5 ou 10 ans, vous
ressortez de là, vous avez fait un
dividende par rapport au prix auquel
vous avez racheté le groupe.
On appelle ça de la Yellow Press. C'est
ça.
Alors on appelait ça de la Yellow Press.
Historiquement, c'est un terme qui est
vachement intéressant ce terme de de
Yellow Press. C'est un terme qui date de
la la fin du 19e siècle, début du 20e
siècle. Alors qui a été développé pour
Pulzer. Ça, on a complètement oublié
parce que maintenant Pulzer c'est le
prix Pulzer donc c'est le symbole du
journalisme de qualité. Mais Puler,
c'était vraiment pas pour le coup un
journaliste qui s'intéressait à la
qualité, mais il s'intéressait au fait
de faire du du nombre et aussi pour et
st c'était le grand concurrent de depuis
10h qui avait racheté tout un certain
nombre de de médias à l'époque qui est
quand même accusé entre guillemets en
tout cas reconnu par les historiens
comme responsable de la guerre entre les
États-Unis et l'Espagne à la fin du 19e
siècle parce qu'il voulait vendre du
papier. Donc lui, il faisait aussi tout
le temps euh des des fake news et puis
c'est lui qui a inspiré à Orson Wells,
son fameux personnage de Magna
médiatique.
On parle on parle on va revenir sur les
fake news d'ailleurs, c'est très
intéressant. On va revenir sur la
propagande médiatique et et sur le fait
que les journalistes ou la presse font
de la terraformation d'opinion publique.
Donc ça ça on va vraiment le creuser.
N'oubliez pas de me le rappeler si je
l'oublie.
Revenons revenons aux journalistes.
Je vais me faire encore l'avocat du
diable parce qu'on les aime beaucoup
mais il faut quand même les scouer très
fort. Et
ah bah parce que vous êtes journaliste
aussi.
Je suis pas journaliste.
À votre manière ? Ah vous avez pas de
carte de presse.
C'est différent. C'est pas pareil de pas
avoir de cartes de presse et de pas être
journaliste. Vous faites des interviews
avec de l'objectivité,
c'est une forme de journalisme.
On est on veut pas être comparé au
journalistes. On est on est loin de ça.
Et on essaie d'être honnête le plus
possible et on essaie quitte à à se
faire violence ne pas
teinter notre nos questions.
Déconcentré là.
Non mais en fait c'est c'est je vous dis
ça parce que c'est c'est vachement
intéressant. Je trouve il y a
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de citoyens
qui veulent se faire reconnaître le
droit d'être reconnus comme journalisme
qui vont en manif qui vont sur le
terrain qui alors certains disent c'est
des reporterurs d'images et justement
moi je pense qu'on devrait leur
reconnaître le le statut de journaliste.
Ils disent nous on fait un boulot on le
fait pas pareil on travaille pas pour
une réduction pour une rédaction on a
notre média indépendant peut-être on
fait juste de l'image qu'on communique
directement aux citoyens mais justement
on fait un boulot de journalistes
d'ailleurs on est sur le terrain et du
coup aujourd'hui on a plutôt tendance à
vouloir refuser l'étiquette de
journaliste à des gens qui essaient de
faire du journalisme. Donc je trouve ça
assez intéressant pour le coup de de
faire quelque chose qu'on peut voir
comme une forme de journalisme en fait,
de faire de l'interview et de refuser
cette étiquette de de journaliste là où
il y a plein d'autres gens qui
voudraient la voir en fait.
Mais c'est pas moi qui vous interview.
Donc
[Rires]
pardon. Donc on on se on pose la
question aux journalistes, on leur dit
"Vilà mais vous plaignez tout le temps,
il y a des fake news tout le temps, vous
plaignez de perdre votre boulot, vous
plaignez tout un tas de trucs, vous vous
êtes tout le temps à vous plaindre alors
que vous êtes perfusé par l'argent de
l'État, que vous avez une niche fiscale,
que vous avez une TVA vachement
avantageuse
et que vous vous plaignez de ne plus
être lu et que vous vous retrouvez avec
des des philanthropes qui vous
rachètent. D'où vient le fait que la
presse s'effondre ? Ça vient du fait que
les journalistes sont un petit peu
accommodés avec leur militantisme et la
et et et la vérité.
Bah ça ça vient d'abord du fait qu'il y
a un problème de modèle économique.
Ensuite sur les messen versus l'argent
public, je pense qu'il faut faire un
choix à un moment donné. C'est-à-dire
que l'info pour moi, c'est un bien
public. Il faut qu'on mette plus
d'argent public pour financer
l'information. Aujourd'hui en France, on
a une TVA réduit à 21. Moi, j'amais très
bien à zéro sur les médias. C'est le cas
par exemple au Royaume-Uni. Et je pense
qu'il faut euh davantage. Bah ça pour le
coup si vous demandiez, je pense que
vous pourriez demander euh pour Syerview
euh le le l'agrément qui serait
l'équivalent, je sais pas comment on
appelle ça pour les chaînes de si je
pense que c'est un numéro de CPPAP. En
fait, la CPPAP donne aussi finalement
cette reconnaissance de médias à des
sites internet. Vous pourriez peut-être
avoir finalement ça pour Syerview et
avoir la TVA à 21 ce qui serait un truc
très bien d'ailleurs et Media Parté un
de leurs combats qu'ils ont porté
beaucoup puisque'au départ cette TVA 21
était réservée à la presse papier et eux
ils disaient mais attendez on a un média
on fait des journal du journalisme on
fait des enquêtes, on a des abonnés
pourquoi on doit payer notre TVA à 20 %
donc ils ont obtenu ça. Mais il y a ce
truc je pense qu'il faut être vachement
clair là-dessus si on veut pas des
médias possédés par des messenes et
possédés par des milliardaires. Et moi
je pense que c'est pas le bon modèle. On
veut des médias qui sont financés par
qui ? Je pense qu'il faut des médias
financés par les citoyens. Donc ça peut
être directement avec du crowfunding, la
communauté qui vous finance et cetera.
Il faut soutenir ça le plus possible et
aussi par les citoyens indirectement,
c'est-à-dire par les impôts. C'est moi
je suis contente aujourd'hui j'ai pas
d'enfant mais je suis contente de payer
mes impôts pour payer l'école, pour
payer l'école pour tout le monde parce
que je veux que tout le monde puisse
être éduqué. Je veux aussi que tout le
monde puisse être informé. Donc je suis
contente que l'argent de mes impôts
servent aussi pour financer des médias.
Alors pourquoi les médias se portent mal
? Il y a un problème de modèle
économique. Pour le faire rapidement, on
a eu des médias des médias de masse qui
ont été financés de 1850 à 1950 1960 en
grande partie par la pub, au moins à
moitié par la pub et c'est ça qui
permettait de vendre des médias à un
prix inférieur à leur coût de fabrique.
Ça a été le cas jusqu'aux années 50 60.
Les recettes publicitaires se sont
effondrées petit à petit. Ça s'est
effrité avec la télé, ça s'est accéléré
avec internet, ça s'est complètement
effondré avec la crise économique. Et
aujourd'hui, vous avez des médias qui en
plus ont fait d'erreur pendant des
années de donner l'info à consommer
gratuitement. Donc en fait, les gens
comprennent plus vraiment pourquoi il
faudrait payer pour de l'info qu'on leur
a donné gratuitement pendant des années.
Il y a plus les revenus publicitaires.
Donc un, il y a un problème pour les
médias qui a un problème de modèle
économique. Il faut retrouver un modèle
économique. Et de en l'absence de modèle
économique, on a fait quoi ? Et ben on a
laissé ces médias être rachetés par des
méenes entre guillemets des grands
industriels qui étaient prêts à perdre
de l'argent dans le secteur des médias.
Attention, je dis perdre de l'argent
dans le secteur des médias parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup qui l'ont fait pour
retrouver de l'argent de l'autre main.
C'est-à-dire que ça leur fait des
entrées. Quand Bezos rachète le
Washington Post, il sait très bien que
ça va l'aider aussi euh pour qu'il y ait
pas trop de régulation du e-commerce aux
États-Unis. Et finalement, les lecteurs
sont pas complètement imbéciles. Ils se
disent quoi les lecteurs ? Ils se disent
"Je consomme aujourd'hui une info que je
ne paye pas. Je la paye pas directement,
je m'abonne pas. Je la paye pas
indirectement parce que de plus en plus
tout le monde met des bloqueurs de
publicité et c'est très bien. Je la pay
pas énormément comme citoyen parce que
il y a des aides à la presse mais en
fait en masse si vous enlevez la TVA à
taux réduit et le soutien public à
l'agence France-press important. Ça, je
vais revenir au niche fiscal. Et à
l'arrivée en fait, ils se disent "Mais
pourquoi il y a des gens qui sont prêts
à payer pour produire de l'info que je
ne paye pas pour consommer ?" Et du
coup, ils s'interrogent et c'est ça qui
crée la défiance. Et c'est ça en fait
qu'il faut repenser sur la niche fiscale
du journaliste. Ça, je pense que c'est
un truc qu'on aurait dû supprimer depuis
longtemps. C'est pas une manière en plus
de subventionner la production
d'information. Quand vous faites la TVA
à taux réduit, ça permet de vendre moins
cher un journal. La niche fiscale, il
faut la supprimer. Après, il faut quand
même savoir que c'est pas rattaché à la
carte de presse. Donc n'importe qui
finalement peut demander à en
bénéficier, en mettant sur sa feuille
d'impôt je suis journaliste et en fait à
partir du moment où l'administration
fiscale le reconnaît comme journaliste,
il bénéficie de cette niche fiscale. Je
pense que c'est une vraie connerie pour
le coup. C'est un peu une spécificité de
la France et je pense que si on l'a
supprimé enfin, on ferait beaucoup de
bien à la profession.
Pour vous, qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur le le
je dirais le trottoir comédia qui fait
correctement son travail ? On prend
souvent comme exemple Disclose.
Ouais.
On prend souvent comme exemple Media
Part. On prend souvent de temps en temps
d'ailleurs Croyer International.
Qui d'autre ?
Bah Disclose, ils font un super boulot.
Moi je les ai vu émerger. C'est cette
ils se volent comme une ONG de de
médias. C'est intéressant. L'info c'est
un bien public. Eux ils font du média
but non lucratif. Ils font de l'enquête.
Ils le font même pas pour eux-mêmes. Ils
la redonnent finalement à d'autres
médias à consommer. Ils font un super
boulot. Média partit un super boulot
reporter euh fait un super boulot les
jours qui est un média indépendant qui
est pareil sur internet avec un
abonnement sans publot.
Euh je pourrais en citer d'autres comme
ça. Il y a il y a beaucoup de médias
notamment de médias en ligne qui ont
complètement révolutionné la manière de
faire du journalisme qui font du super
boulot. Une fois que j'ai dit ça, moi je
pense qu'on ne peut pas vivre uniquement
avec ces nouveaux médias indépendants en
ligne qui ont des rédactions
relativement petite et qu'on a et
complètement précaire. Mais ça c'est
vrai aussi pour les journalistes qui
bossent pour de pour de gros médias et
qu'on a aussi encore besoin de médias
traditionnels comme le monde comme
Libération. Si on parle sur tout le
spreectre comme les échos, le Figaro, ça
ça dépend si vous voulez vous informer
plutôt à droite ou plus plutôt à gauche
qu'on en a encore besoin et qu'on a
besoin que ces médiasl aussi soient des
médias indépendants. Et c'est pour ça
que j'ai créé avec d'autres
l'association un bout du monde pour
partir à la reconquête des médias
d'information et pour essayer de refaire
de ces médias des médias qui soient
possédés et surtout gouvernés en partie
et par leurs journalistes et par leurs
citoyens. Je pense qu'on peut pas
abandonner ces médias-là parce que c'est
des médias qui informment aujourd'hui
des centaines de milliers des millions
de citoyens et que c'est aussi par
rapport à ces médias là que la défiance
s'est accumulée au cours des années.
Le pire journal pour vous c'est lequel ?
Bah c'est valeur actuelle.
Pourquoi ?
Bah là, je pense qu'il y a il y a il y a
on pourrait penser que c'est simplement
du biais politique et c'est vrai que
j'ai un vrai problème avec l'idéologie,
les idées de l'extrême droite. Je les ai
toujours combattu et je les combattrai
toujours. Mais là, c'est au-delà de ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a non seulement
l'extrême droite, l'idéologie de
l'extrême droite, le racisme, la haine
de l'étranger, la haine de l'autre et en
plus dessus, il y a de il y a de la
diffamation. Ils ont été condamnés
plusieurs fois pour diffamation. qui
sont racistes.
Bah je sais pas, je pourrais vous
démultiplier les unes de Christian
Tobira à Daniel Obon. Enfin les les
J'arrête même de lire valeur actuelle
enfin je ne l'ai jamais lu mais il se
trouve que en fait il
ils ont été condamnés ou pas ?
Ils ont été condamnés sur Christian
Tobirat. D'ailleurs, ils ont été privés
d'une partie de leurs aides à la presse
à cause de ça pendant un certain temps.
Sur Obonau sur Bono, je sais pas c'est
une bonne question. Je pense qu'il y a
eu une plainte qui a été déposée. En
tout cas une plainte aurait dû être
déposée. Je pense que ça a été le cas.
Je pense que le jugement a pas dû encore
avoir lieu.
On va parler d'ailleurs de de ça, de ce
clivage journalistique. On dit tout le
temps que 99 % des journalistes sont de
gauche.
Moi là, j'aurais dit plutôt récemment
que 99 % des journalistes étaient
macronistes. Comme je mets Macron à
droite, je serai pas d'accord avec vous.
Belle pirouette, est-ce qu'il faut une
presse aussi de droite forte ? Est-ce
qu'il faut ou sinon est-ce qu'il faut
comme l'ultra gauche dit souvent, il
faut pas les laisser parler, il faut pas
les écouter ?
Non, je suis pas d'accord avec ça. C'est
c'est notamment c'est je crois la gerie
qui qui pousse beaucoup ce ce discours,
c'est c'est c'est ces temps-ci et je
suis pas je suis pas d'accord avec lui
par rapport à ça. Moi au contraire, je
pense qu'il faut porter la
contradiction. Il a raison de dire que
il y a tout un discours qui est un
discours de droite notamment sur les
questions économiques qui a un discours
ultralibéral du point de vue économique
qui va toujours nous vendre que par
exemple la France, il y a trop de
dépenses sociales, il y a un trop gros
poids de l'État et cetera et finalement
ce ce ce discours, hop
il il est étalé dans tous les médias.
Est-ce que il faut priver ce discours de
parole ou est-ce qu'il faut lui apporter
la contradiction ? Moi je pense qu'il
faut lui apporter la contradiction parce
qu'il faut aller convaincre des
citoyens, il faut aller convaincre des
électeurs. Donc il faut pas avoir peur
d'aller débattre, il faut aller
débattre. Ensuite dire ça, c'est un tout
petit peu différent de dire est-ce qu'il
faut une presse de droite, une presse de
gauche ? Je veux dire quand l'ultra
gauche dit il faut plus donner la parole
au mec de droite, elle dit pas qu'il
faut supprimer le Figaro, elle dit juste
qu'il faut ignorer le Figaro. Mais quand
elle dit ça, elle renonce aussi à les
convaincre les lecteurs du Figaro. Moi,
je pense que le pluralisme, c'est
important. Le pluralisme, ça va de
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite. Et
je pense que ce pluralisme, il faut
l'assurer, y compris dans les médias. Et
je pense que les journalistes, ils ont
pas forcément pour vocation à être
objectif. De toute façon, il ils sont
politiques comme citoyens. C'est des
citoyens qui votent et qui parlent. Mais
par contre, on peut pas avoir que des
journalistes de droite. On peut pas
avoir que des journalistes de gauche. Et
surtout quand un journaliste fait son
boulot dans un média, il doit faire son
boulot en toute indépendance par rapport
à son actionnaire. Je pense qu'il doit
assumer sa subjectivité de journaliste,
mais par contre il ne doit pas être
empêché dans ce qu'il dit par la
décision d'un actionnaire. Autocensure,
c'est ça ?
Bah l'autocensure, c'est un véritable
problème du journalisme. Quand vous êtes
aujourd'hui, vous bossez pour BFM TV ou
vous bossez pour RMC, que votre patron
c'est Patrick Draille, vous êtes possédé
par Altis, comment vous allez parler de
la 5G ? Vous pouvez pas parler de la 5G,
vous pouvez pas traiter fondamentalement
de la 5G euh ou prenons puisque je vous
parle d'un bout du monde. Euh dans un
bout du monde, il y a le monde et c'est
quand même une association qui est née
aussi parce que j'ai été élu à la
présidence de la société des lecteurs du
monde et parce qu'il y a cette idée de
revenir justement à ce qu'a
l'actionnariat historique du monde, un
actionnariat de lecteur et un
actionnariat de journaliste.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez un des
actionnaires du monde, Xavier Niel qui
est aussi un géant des télécom. Alors,
les journalistes vont toujours dire
qu'ils prennent le recul nécessaire et
que dès qu'ils parlent de Xavinel, ils
vont mettre entre trucs euh actionnaire
euh du média, je pense que c'est
compliqué pour un journaliste de faire
un portrait objectif de son actionnaire
et c'est compliqué pour un journaliste
de parler objectivement des activités de
son actionnaire. Je veux pas dire qu'il
va pas essayer de le faire le
journaliste du Washington Post, il va
essayer de parler peut-être de Jeff
Bezos ou de Amazon, il peut pas le faire
librement. C'est juste pas possible. Et
c'est ça qu'on appelle l'autocenseur. Et
le problème, c'est d'avoir mis les
journalistes dans cette situation là.
C'est pas la faute du journaliste.
Vous êtes sûr de l'autocensure ? Il y a
pas il y a pas des têtes brûlées qui
disent "Moi, j'en ai rien à faire."
Bien sûr qu'il y en a toujours la
question c'est la rédaction dans son
ensemble. Vous prenez une rédaction de
300 400 personnes. Bien sûr, vous allez
toujours trouver une tête brûlée qui va
être capable de de de claquer la porte
et de dire qu'il en a rien à faire et
tant mieux. Mais c'est pas en se
reposant là-dessus qu'on va se dire tout
va bien, vous avez plein de fois où ça
va pas. Et puis ça ça interroge aussi
parce qu'il y a l'autocensure et
régulièrement il y a la censure. Là vous
avez vu pareil la semaine dernière, paf,
vous avez un journaliste qui se fait euh
virer de canal Manu military parce qu'il
a fait une parodie de leur dépos. Bon et
ben, est-ce que vous pensez vraiment euh
que les autres journalistes qui restent
à canal, en plus dans une profession qui
est précarisée, vont faire des parodies
de leur des pros ? Bah non, c'est de
l'autocensur lui peut-être il a été tête
brûlée, bah il a quand même perdu son
poste au passage. Donc je pense
qu'ensuite on fait gaffe et on fait
d'autant plus gaffe que c'était c'était
plus simple d'être peut-être brûlée dans
les médias il y a 30 ans ou il y a 20
ans. C'était une profession où il y
avait du job, enfin il y avait du
travail. Vous trouviez des jobs
ailleurs, passer d'une rédaction à
l'autre finalement et vous étiez
relativement bien payé. Et d'ailleurs,
on avait un truc qui s'appelait la
clause de session qu'on a toujours mais
qui est une bonne chose, qui dit que
quand vous avez un changement
d'actionnariat dans un média, un
journaliste peut partir dans de bonnes
condition justement pour pas se mettre à
bosser pour un actionnaire qu'il aurait
pas choisi. Sauf qu'aujourd'hui la
clause de session, ça existe sur le
papier, mais comme il y a pas de travail
ailleurs, nombre de cartes de presse se
réduit petit à petit, mais même hors des
cartes de presse, vous avez des
rédactions qui s'effritent petit à
petit, vous allez où ? Je veux dire, les
gens, ils ont besoin d'avoir un boulot.
Et du coup, c'est ça aussi qui crée
cette autocensure, c'est la
précarisation croissante de la
profession.
C'est quoi un bon journaliste ?
Un bon journaliste, c'est un journaliste
qui travaille en toute objectivité. Pour
moi, c'est un journaliste qui apporte
quelque chose sur la table. Donc c'est
un journaliste qui fait de l'enquête,
qui rapporte des faits. Euh je suis pas
fan du tout des journalistes d'opinion
pour le coup quand quand je vois juste
des débats d'opinion euh ou que je vois
du journalisme culturel, je considère
pas que ça soit du bon journalisme. Non,
il y a pas que ça. Euh et vous avez même
euh de gros médias, euh bah par exemple,
vous avez tout un truc qui est sorti
hier, euh je crois que c'était le
consortium international de de
journalisme. Vous aviez Radio France
dedans, vous aviez le monde, vous aviez
d'autres médias qui ont fait tout un
truc sur le cartel au Mexique. Ils ont
fait une vraie enquête. Ça c'est du bon
journalisme. Vous apportez des faits sur
la table. Et quand vous éclairez un truc
aussi, comme lecteur, j'ai besoin
d'apprendre des choses. Comme lecteur,
je suis pas forcé de savoir si tel ou
tel sort avec tel ou tel ou alors si on
a eu une petite phrase. Un truc qui pour
moi est pas du bon journalisme. Euh
c'est quand à la place de rentrer euh
dans le détail euh de la loi sécurité
globale, de voir ce qui va pas, de
déconstruire l'article 24, euh on a un
proche à dit, un ministre a dit selon
ses collaborateurs peut-être.
Franchement, des citations entre
guillemets sans la source pour moi,
c'est pas du bon journalisme. Un
journaliste par contre, et ça je l'ai lu
à peu près nulle part, qui va me faire
un bilan complet partout en Europe, des
lois qui encadrent en Allemagne, en
Belgique, en Suède, en Suisse, en
Espagne, en Italie, la liberté de filmer
et de diffuser des images de policiers.
Pour moi, c'est du bon journalisme parce
que ça apporte de l'information et un
journaliste, il est là pour nous
informer.
Comment vous percevez le fait que les
journalistes leur liberté se réduit un
peu comme pot de chagrin, que il y a des
perquisitions dans certaines rédactes,
qu'il y a des coups de pression, que des
intimidations, des procédures billons,
c'est c'est est-ce que vous sentez en
fait les bruits de bottes arrivés ?
Je déteste cette expression de de bruit
de botte. Bah, je trouve cette idée de
de récidive là, ce truc selon lequel on
reviendrait au aux années 30. Alors
après, on nous parle de rouge, brun et
cetera. Pareil, c'est une manière de pas
trop réfléchir. On ressort toujours les
années 30 et comme ça on est là. Et
d'ailleurs souvent c'est utilisé
vachement contre contre l'extrême
gauche. Euh une manière de dire c'est
utilisé vachement par l'extrême gauche.
Oui. Alors contre l'extrême droite, mais
enfin c'est une manière de pas se poser
les les questions sur le fond. Je pense
que la situation aujourd'hui est assez
complexe pour qu'on ait pas besoin de de
revenir un siècle en arrière. Qu'est-ce
qu'elle nous dit la situation
aujourd'hui ? c'est que vous avez de
plus en plus d'attaques qui sont portées
y compris par les pouvoirs publics, y
compris par le gouvernement, contre les
journalistes et contre la liberté
d'informer. La loi sécurité globale,
l'article 24 et d'ailleurs pas que
l'article 24, l'article 21 22,
l'utilisation des drones, ils sont
également extrêmement problématiques,
pas que ces articlesl cette loi sécurité
globale, elle pose des problèmes. C'est
une atteinte sur la liberté d'informer.
On va voir ce qui va être mis dans la
loi sur le séparatisme. Ça va pas être
beaucoup mieux. dans la loi Avia qui
était passée cet été, il y a le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a retoqué la
disposition qui pareil elle a été
retoquée parce qu'elle allait contre la
liberté de la presse avec Emmanuel
Macron. Il y a pas eu que Macron mais
quand même historiquement le fait de
taper sur les journalistes y compris de
secouer les journalistes en meeting et
cetera, c'était un truc de l'extrême
droite. L'extrême droite l'a toujours
fait.
elle bah euh vous alliez aux
manifestations du Front National le 1er
mai, vous aviez des journalistes qui
étaient secoués, c'est-à-dire secoués
euh physiquement euh par des euh des des
mecs qui encadraient les manifes de de
l'extrême droite. Ouais. par les gories
de l'extrême droite. Ça ça a été ça a
toujours été le cas. Il y a eu un
tournant moi qui m'a frappé au moment de
la présidentielle de de 2017, c'était de
voir des attaques contre les médias, y
compris par des candidats qui étaient
des candidats de parti traditionnel.
Coupe, je vous coupe, je vous coupe, je
suis désolé. Allez-y.
Euh il y a aussi des journalistes entre
guillemets perçus comme de droite qui se
font aussi secouer dans les manifes
parce qu'ils sont pas de la branche
politique.
H
est-ce que c'est normal ça ?
Non, c'est pas normal. Faut pas scouer
un journaliste parce qu'un journaliste,
il est là pour faire son boulot. Son
boulot, c'est d'informer. Il faut le
respecter dans son le fait d'informer.
Un des trucs qui m'a frappé pendant les
gilets jaunes, par exemple, c'est toutes
les grandes manifes qui avaient lieu
sous BFM TV. Je peux vous assurer que
vous auriez fait une enquête parmi les
mecs qui bossent à BFM TV, les
techniciens qui bossent à BFM TV, plein
de journalistes que vous voyez pas à BFM
TV du tout, ils étaient majoritairement
gilets jaunes. Alors forcément, les
trois journalistes qui sont tous les
jours à l'antenne avec le maquillage en
train de sourire, eux ils sont pas
gilets jaunes. Ils sont payés beaucoup
plus, ils ont la sécurité de l'emploi et
puis ils ont aussi tout un certain
prestige et eux ils le sont pas mais la
plupart des salariés qui bossent pour
ces boîtes-là ou qui bossent pour des
titres de presse he avant Drahi
possédait l'Express, il a réduit
l'express à peau de chagrin. Il arrêtait
même de payer ses pigistes. Payez plus
les photographes, payez les gens en
facture. Donc quand vous êtes payé en
facture, en fait avec la carte de
presse, vous avez pas le droit
normalement d'être journaliste. Il
forçaiit à payer les gens en facture.
C'était pas des gens euh qui était de
droite, mais on a identifié finalement
tous les journalistes à une espèce
d'intelligentia. C'est ça qui fait euh
que les journalistes sont bousculés, y
compris dans des manifes du coup de
gauche et puis dans les manifes
d'extrême droite, on les bouscule parce
qu'on les aime pas non plus. Et vous
avez aussi du coup dans les parties
traditionnelles, je me souviens très
bien, Fillon qui faisait siffler les
journalistes. Après Macron, il a fait ça
aussi. il a fait euh un euh il a eu une
des premières mesures qu'il a faites euh
qui peut sembler anecdotique mais qui
était extrêmement violente, c'était de
sortir la FP de l'Élysée où la FP avait
toujours été c'est une agence de presse
la FP qui est là pour informer et c'est
normal qu'elle soit au plus près du
pouvoir pour informer. On n pas allé la
mettre dans un placard de l'autre côté
de la rue.
Près du pouvoir ou sous le robinet de
l'information du pouvoir ? Bah quand
vous êtes agencier à l'Élysée, forcément
c'est plus simple pour obtenir des
dépêches. Ça c'est vrai, mais ça vous
permet aussi d'observer ce qu'on veut
pas forcément vous montrer, c'est-à-dire
qui rentre, qui sortent les les venus.
Ça veut pas dire que le mec de la FP est
journaliste à la FP pour aller prendre
des dépêches qui est donné par le
pouvoir, mais il est là aussi pour
observer. Et le fait de les retirer de
l'Élysée, c'était une manière de les
éloigner justement pour dire qu'il y
avait pas de raison qui soi au cœur de
ce pouvoir pour pouvoir justement
observer ce qui était en train de de se
passer. Il y a eu toute la problématique
autour des accréditations. Il y a eu
tout ce qui a été fait au moment de
Benala.
La problématique sur les accréditations.
Bah si vous voulez là sur tous les
déplacements d'Emmanuel Macron au cours
des dernières semaines, c'est des
déplacements auxquels la presse est plus
accrédité. Donc il y a plus d'images.
Vous pouvez plus faire vos images. Donc
vous faites quoi ? Vous prenez les
images officielles.
Je peux être vulgaire. Il faut bien
lécher pour être accrédité.
Bah non, justement dans une démocratie,
il faut pas lécher pour être accrédité.
Dans une démocratie, vous avez une carte
de presse, vous êtes accrédité. Voilà. À
la limite, on pourrait même se dire
qu'il faut pas forcément une carte de
presse, mais il y a un événement, vous
êtes un média, vous allez couvrir
l'événement, c'est votre droit, il faut
pas la demander la créditation. Alors
après pour les voyages officiels, on va
dire "Ah oui, mais il y a une petit un
petit nombre de places dans le train ou
dans l'avion." OK, mais quand vous avez
des événements qui sont organisés, il y
a eu cette problématique pendant les
meetings de campagne. Vous aviez des
meetings de campagne où les caméras des
médias pouvaient plus rentrer. C'était
que les images officielles. Ça c'est des
atteintes contre la liberté d'informer.
Ensuite, ça c'est encore plus grave.
Vous parliez des procédures bayon, il y
a tout ce qui a été introduit dans les
lois euh autour du secret des affaires.
La directive secret des affaires, elle
était déjà pas terrible au niveau
européen, mais alors sa retranscription
en droit français, c'est une manière
d'empêcher euh les journalistes de faire
leur boulot. Et vous les empêchez de
deux manières, c'est que un, ces
procédures bayon, parfois elles ont des
effets très concrets. Deux, interroger
un Fabrice Fabrice Arfi, il va vous dire
quoi ? bah que souvent en fait à la
place de pouvoir faire son boulot, il
est assis sur un banc au tribunal parce
qu'en fait on démultiplie les procédures
contre lui même si on sait finalement
qu'à l'arrivée on va les perdre pour ben
le pousser à plus travailler et ça prend
un temps fou en fait dans son temps de
travail c'est d'être au tribunal pour
aller gagner des procès qui lui sont
intentés. Et là-dessus, il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on protège collectivement
les journalistes. Et c'est pour ça moi
j'ai pas envie de de de de dire tiens,
il faut pleurer sur cette pauvre
profession de journaliste. Euh c'est
juste que les journalistes, on en a
besoin pour être informé. en démocratie
et qu'aujourd'hui on leur porte beaucoup
de coups. Mais comme il y a en plus ce
problème de la défiance dans les
journalistes qui est lié en partie à la
structure de l'actionnariat, il y a plus
personne pour les Ouais.
Mais du coup, il y a plus personne pour
les défendre même quand ils sont
attaqués. Donc on fait comment à
l'arrivée ? Je vous on va dire depuis
les 20 dernières années, les 30
dernières années, ils sont fait, je dis
il je sais que c'est c'est c'est pas
c'est pas la bonne expression de les
englober tous, mais
il est elle
et bien entendu et il y en a qui ont
fait beaucoup de merde.
Ouais, bien sûr, mais dans tous les
métiers, dans toutes ces professions,
sauf que ça c'est pas ça c'est pas la
même profession que monsieur tout le
monde.
Non, ça c'est vrai. Mais vous avez des
journalistes qui ont pas bien fait leur
boulot. Vous avez des médias qui ont pas
bien fait leur boulot. Et d'ailleurs, il
faut s'interroger. Est-ce qu'il faut un
comité de déontologie qui est mis en
place ou pas ? Il y en a un qui a été
mis en place l'an dernier. Il a été
beaucoup critiqué. C'est quoi
de quoi ?
La charte de Munique.
La charte Dominique, je sais pas ce que
c'est. Du coup, vous m'avez coincé.
C'est quoi ?
Non mais dites-moi parce que du coup, on
peut pas en discuter sinon.
C'est l'équivalent du serment
d'Hippocrate mais pour le journaliste.
OK. Bah, ça doit être une charte qui dit
qu'il faut informer de manière objective
en toute liberté, en toute indépendance.
En gros, c'est ça. Ouais. La plupart se
je vais être encore vulgaire, je suis
désolé mais la plupart se torche avec.
Non
mais dites pas la plupart en fait le
problème c'est que ce que vous vous
rendez pas compte Non mais c'est
justement ça qui est problématique d'une
certaine manière. La plupart des gens
qui choisissent de faire des du
journalisme c'est des mecs qui ont 10 15
ans, 18 ans, 20 ans, 25 ans. Ils veulent
juste informer, ils veulent juste faire
du journalisme, ils veulent faire de
l'enquête, ils veulent faire leur
métier. Ensuite, ils vont bosser dans
des rédactions où déjà souvent
aujourd'hui ils vont être précarisés.
Ensuite euh du fait de la structure de
l'actionnariat, ils vont être parfois
victimes de la censure, parfois victime
de l'autocensure et parfois ils vont pas
bien faire leur boulot. Mais la plupart
quand ils veulent faire ça, ils veulent
bien faire leur boulot. Et le problème
c'est qu'en tapons sur les journalistes,
on tape pas sur le système. Et ce qu'il
faut changer, c'est le système de
d'actionnariat aujourd'hui des médias.
Il faut déconcentrer les médias. Il faut
mettre fin à un actionat des médias
uniquement entre les mains de gros
industriels. Il faut repenser des médias
indépendants. Il faut pas taper sur les
journalistes.
On entend on entend souvent, on lit
souvent sur internet dans des
commentaires, dans la perception que les
défiants ont.
Ils disent voilà les étudiants
journalistes en journalisme pardon, ce
sont simplement des militants politiques
qui se drape dans la vertu
journalistique pour continuer d'essé
leurs idées protégées par le
journalisme. Qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur
répondre à ces gens-là ?
Mais que c'est pas le cas. La plupart
des étudiants en journalistes, c'est
juste des gens qui ont envie d'aller sur
le terrain, faire de l'enquête, faire
des reportages. Ça veut pas dire que
certains d'entre eux ont pas des des
billets politiques, des positions
politiques. C'est des citoyens. Mais
c'est comme si vous me disiez moi que
j'ai choisi d'être prof euh pour aller
essimer mes idées. Je veux dire, j'ai
une ligne politique qui est plutôt bien
assumée. D'ailleurs, je l'assume plutôt
très bien dans mes bouquins. Euh mais
quand je suis prof euh devant mes
étudiants, j'essaie de leur enseigner
des faits, des trucs objectifs.
J'enseigne l'économie. Donc je renseigne
qu'est-ce que c'est que le PIB, comment
ça se mesure, le revenu national, la
croissance, les limites de Ah non, enfin
c'est une science au sens de science
sociale mais c'est certainement pas une
science dure.
Revenons au journalisme, on repassera à
l'économie après. Est-ce que je pense
qu'on va bien creuser ?
On fait quoi pour les sauver ? C'est pas
trop tard. Est-ce que la défiance est
est tellement importante envers la
profession ? Est-ce que le climat
socio-économique n'est pas tellement
délétaire que c'est foutu et qu'il faut
attendre il faut attendre que ça touche
le fond pour recréer ?
Ah ça j'y crois pas. Moi, je crois pas à
la la stratégie de la terre brûlée. Je
crois pas qu'il faut vraiment attendre
vraiment qu'on ait touché le fond pour
recommencer parce que là en fait
sérieusement pour un certain nombre de
médias de rédactions qui subissent les
coups de boutoir de d'actionnaires,
c'est c'est déjà fini. Je veux dire rien
que cette année, je pourrais reprendre
là je vous parlais de sciences et vi
vous avez dans la même année les les
cahiers du cinéma qui ont disparu, le
nouveau magazine littéraire qui a
disparu, Libération qui est passée sous
un fond de dotation qui a en tout et
pour tout une gouvernance avec trois
membres qui a pas été assez doté. On va
pas leur laisser les moyens de de
bosser. Vous avez un plan social euh à
l'équipe, vous avez des des coupes qui
ont été fait au aux Parisiens. Je peux
vous prendre tout le paysage médiatique,
il se portent de moins en moins bien.
Vous avez de plus en plus de coûts qui
sont portés. Donc on va on va faire ça
jusqu'à quand ? Je veux dire, jusqu'à
tant que tout le monde a quitté la
profession de journaliste et que tous
les médias qui existaient depuis 40 ans
ai disparu. Encore une fois, moi je
pense, je suis abonné au jour, je suis
abonné à à à Media Part, je je je je je
je je je vais sur Reporter, je vais sur
le vent se lève, j'ai soutenu dès leur
création d'Clos. Je peux vous en citer
plein de de nouveaux médias et je passe
plus de temps en fait à les consommer
que ce qu'on va appeler les grands
médias traditionnels. Sauf que je pense
qu'on ne peut pas faire sans ces grands
médias traditionnels et qu'il faut faire
en sorte d'améliorer la situation. C'est
pour ça que j'essaie de me battre, c'est
pour ça que je fais des trucs. Et c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé l'association Un
bout du monde. On a créé l'association
Un bout du monde pour remettre les
journalistes et les citoyens au cœur de
la gouvernance et de l'actionnariat des
médias. Pour ça, on fait quoi ? On
essaie de lever de l'argent et on essaie
de lever de l'argent pour proposer des
alternatives pour faire rentrer bah là
on finit une campagne de financement
participatif sur Kiskiss Bang pour lever
150000 €. On les avait quasiment levé
avant l'émission. Je pense qu'on les
aura levé à la fin de l'émission. On a
2000 personnes qui ont adhéré. 150000 €
c'éit un début. C'était l'idée de faire
la campagne de financement participatif.
Si on peut lever 500000 c'est mieux. Si
on peut lever 1 million d'euros, c'est
encore mieux. Parce que pour le coup,
c'est un truc de poids du nombre. Il se
trouve que vous avez en France un petit
nombre d'individus euh qui ont 500
millions ou 1 milliard d'euros à mettre
sur la table. Bon bah nous la plupart
des gens normaux petits humains sur
cette planète, on n' pas ça. Par contre
si vous prenez euh 100 millions de
visiteurs uniques euh par mois sur un
site internet qui donne chacun 5 € ben
ça fait 50 millions d'euros et là vous
pouvez faire la différence. Mais si vous
voulez faire la différence, il faut
convaincre les citoyens que ça vaut le
coup en fait de mener cette reconquête
démocratique des médias. Et moi je pense
que ça vaut le coup. Je pense que les
meilleurs garantind
des médias, c'est les citoyens eux-mêmes
et des journalistes.
Question d'internet de Exoet,
euh que pensent-elle des décodeurs du
monde ?
Bah, ils font du fact checking. Euh
c'est un truc qui est en train de se
développer de plus en plus. Vous avez
les décodeurs qui le font, vous avez
Libération qui le fait, vous avez l'AFP
qui le fait.
C'est un truc qui est utile au sens où
ça permet de de débunker des fake news.
L'utilité réelle pour convaincre les
gens qu'une fake news est une fake news.
Ça, on s'interroge encore un peu
là-dessus. C'est-à-dire que une fois que
la fake news a été propagée, est-ce que
le fait de décoder finalement ça c'est
c'est pas un peu l'effet stressés ?
C'està-dire ça va pas lui redonner une
amplification ? Moi la question que je
me pose fondamentalement c'est est-ce
qu'on passe pas trop de temps
aujourd'hui à décortiquer les fake news
plutôt qu'à produire de la vraie
information ? Mais s'ils le font, c'est
que finalement on a on n pas le choix.
On est dans un univers quand même où il
y a de plus en plus
Oh ! Sur les sur les décodeurs, je pense
que du coup la question est posée parce
que ça a été financé en partie par
Facebook. Euh je pense que c'était pas
une très bonne idée pour toutes les
rédactions qui ont fait ce choix-là de
faire un partenariat avec Facebook. Je
pense que ce travail de décodage de
l'information, ça devrait faire partie
du travail des rédactions en elle-même
et qu'elle devrait pas être payée en
particulier par un réseau social pour le
faire. Pourquoi ils l'ont fait en
partenariat avec Facebook ? parce qu'on
a un problème de modèle économique, que
vous avez des médias qui recherchent de
plus en plus d'argent, qui a de plus en
plus de fake news sur Facebook et que
Facebook qui paye pas ses impôts, qui
fait de l'argent avec de la pub sur des
contenus qu'ils ont pas produit, eux ils
ont de l'argent à redistribuer. Je pense
que les décodeurs se porteraient mieux,
y compris dans la perception extérieure
s'il y avait pas ces contrats de de
partenariat financier avec avec les
réseaux sociaux. Il faut que l'État
fasse son boulot, fasse payer les impôts
et ensuite redistribue.
Bah en fait moi la proposition que j'ai
par rapport à ça, c'est de faire de ce
que j'ai appelé des bons pour
l'indépendance des médias. Je pense
qu'il faut un financement public des
médias. Ensuite, vous voulez pas que ce
financement ça soit l'État qui décide
comment distribuer l'argent. Alors, une
manière qui est pas mal de le faire,
c'est la TVA à t réduit. Au moins, ça
profite à tout le monde et à tous les
médias de la même manière. Ensuite, vous
avez plein d'aides à la presse
aujourd'hui qui sont ultra compliquées,
des aides à la modernisation et cetera.
Et en fait, ça laisse justement à l'état
potentiellement la possibilité de
d'intervenir, de changer telle ou telle
règle pour financer tel ou tel média. Ça
ça va pas, ça alimente la défiance,
c'est pas efficace et en plus c'est
mauvais pour l'indépendance des médias.
Pour ça qu'on fait pas la TVA réduite
du coup. Ouais, mais la TVA a tout
réduit pour le coup, c'est pour tout le
monde. Donc en gros, vous demandez votre
numéro de CPPAP, vous l'obtenez, vous
avez des milliers de publications qui
l'ont chaque année. Ça vous permet juste
de payer 2 % de TVA plutôt de 18 et de
vous, je sais pas acheter une caméra
supplémentaire ou de mieux payer vos
techniciens, de faire un peu mieux votre
boulot et finalement vous la méritez
cette TVA là parce que ce que vous
faites, je sais que ça vous plaît pas
mais je considère quand même que c'est
du journalisme. Bon euh ensuite sur
cette question du financement public des
médias, moi je dis on va prendre les
sommes en jeu aujourd'hui pour le
financement des aides à la presse. On va
les découper entre tous les citoyens et
on va filer à chaque citoyen ce que j'ai
appelé un bon pour l'indépendance des
médias. C'est-à-dire qu'à la place que
ça soit l'État qui alloue les aides à la
presse, c'est chacun d'entre nous qui va
allouer son bon pour l'indépendance des
médias au médias, au singulier ou au
pluriel de son choix. Voilà. Euh et ça
se fait pas à travers un abonnement ou
un crédit sur un abonnement parce que je
pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on puisse
aider et financer des médias qui sont
des médias gratuits. Et en fait, c'est
une manière de dire l'État fait son
boulot, on met de l'argent public pour
financer un bien public, c'est-à-dire
l'information. Donc l'État fait son
boulot de ce point de vue-là et ensuite
c'est les citoyens qui décident de la
location de cet argent.
Revenons à un dossier qui qui est qui
est passé il y a il y a pas très
longtemps, le le pseudo documentaire
sur le Covid-19 qui s'appelle HOP.
Comment vous trouvez la la gestion de la
de la presse sur cet épiphénomène ?
Est-ce que ça a été est-ce que ça a été
un phénomène de cast en disant voilà
nous on est journaliste, on va vous
expliquer que en gros vous êtes des
débiles mentaux, vous êtes en plus débil
mentaux et toxicoman à ce genre de merde
et et on va continuer de vous cracher à
la gueule mais bien profond.
Bah alors, présentez comme ça, comment
vous voulez que je réponde ? Moi je
pense que ce documentaire, il était
presque inexistant
et il serait resté inexistant. C'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure avec
le problème du fact checking, c'est que
vous faites un effet strés. Personne
n'en aurait parlé. Il y avait la la
petite communauté par entre guillemets
les complotistes à des débiles mentaux,
ça ne fait que les renforcer.
En fait la question c'est jusque où vous
faites du fact checking ? Si un mec vous
dit la terre est plate, bon vous allez
pas aller le fa checker parce que d'une
certaine façon un, c'est pas un propos
qui est potentiellement dangereux et
puis de vous dites que en fait 99,9 % de
la population va pas le croire et que la
terre est pas plate. Maintenant si
quelqu'un vous dit que si un mec
d'extrême droite dit la terre est ronde.
Ah mais c'est pas parce qu'il est
d'extrême droite qu'il dit que des
conneries. Enfin et ça serait enfin ça
serait beaucoup mieux d'ailleurs si les
gens d'extrême droite disaient que des
conneries euh ils auraient moins de
poids dans les urnes. Mais maintenant si
quelqu'un vous dit alors ça peut être
Trump il vous dit vous prenez de l'eau
javel si vous avez le Covid-19 bonà
c'est quand même un tout petit peu
embêtant. Alors, pour vous dire, on va
pas le fact checker parce que bon, ça
sert à rien. Mais si maintenant on vous
dit par exemple que hydroxychloroine,
alors là c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué parce que là déjà on rentre
dans une controverse qui est une
controverse scientifique et là pour le
coup il y a un rôle à jouer des
journalistes.
Je veux dire mois journalist il y a plus
de journaliste scientifique. Ah bah
ouais mais tout à l'heure on parlait de
sciences vi c'est pour ça aussi que
quand il y en a il faut se mobiliser
pour les protéger et leur permettre de
faire leur boulot. Mais prenons le le
cas d'hydroxychloroine et de Didier
Raou. Moi perso, j'ai fait j'ai fait de
l'écho, j'ai fait des sciences sociales,
j'ai pas fait de sciences dures. Je suis
pas capable fondamentalement de lire
toutes les publications scientifiques
qui vont me dire si oui ou non c'est
efficace et c'est pas mon boulot et j'ai
pas le temps et comme citoyenne pourtant
j'ai envie d'être informée. Bah ça
normalement c'est le boulot des
journalistes de le faire et de me dire
si finalement avec ce qui est publié à
droite ce qui est publié à gauche ça
marche plutôt bien ou pas
l'hydroxychloroquine.
C'est pareil pour les vaccins. Je veux
dire là pour les vaccins euh moi perso,
je vous dis mon opinion mais là c'est
pour le coup c'est pas une opinion de
chercheur, c'est comme citoyen. Ouais,
je vais me faire vacciner. J'ai plutôt
tendance à à croire en la science et je
vais plutôt me faire vacciner. En même
temps, pour le coup, je comprends
parfaitement les gens qui s'interrogent.
Pendant des années, on nous a dit que un
vaccin, ça prenait entre 5 et 10 ans
pour être développé. En avril de l'an
dernier, on nous disait même que pour la
COVID-19, en mettant tous les moyens du
monde, il faudrait peut-être 3 4 5 ans
et qu'un vaccin, on l'aurait pas en 1
an. Là, on a un vaccin en 1 an. Moi, je
comprends vraiment que les gens
s'interrogent. Je comprends que les gens
s'interrogent et ça fait partie du
boulot des journalistes de dire le pour
et de dire le contre. Là où il y a pas
de journalisme et on aurait un mauvais
journalisme et on aurait un problème,
c'est si vous avez des journalistes
parce que soit ils font des ménages pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique, soit vous
avez des pubs qui sont payées par
l'industrie pharmaceutique ou du de la
du public reportage, vous avez des
journalistes qui vous disent "Ah, il
faut prendre le vaccin parce qu'ils sont
payés pour là, c'est plus l'info, ça va
pas du tout." Par contre, le fait qu'on
nous informe là-dessus ou qu'on prend un
documentaire comme Holdup et qu'on
essaie de voir ce qui est vrai, ce qui
est faux,
une question légitime qui le soulève, la
gestion de la crise,
ils ont raison de soulever des questions
légitimes et tout était pas faux dans le
documentaire. Je dire prenez de la
minute 1 à la minute he
et en même temps, il y avait énormément
de choses à mettre à la poubelle. Mais à
partir du moment où tout était pas faux
et que c'était légitime de s'interroger,
c'est là où je voulais en venir. C'est
pas évident sur les hydroxychloroquines
ni sur les vaccins. Donc en fait, vous
voyez des gens qui allaient regarder ce
documentaire. C'est pas prendre les gens
pour des cons de dire c'est des
complotistes et de les montrer du doigt.
C'est prendre les gens pour des gens
intelligents et de leur dire "Attendez,
vous consommez ça. Nous, on va vous dire
ce qui est vrai, ce qui est faux.
Faites-vous votre opinion." Si vous
voulez que les gens se fassent leur
opinion, il faut les informer. Et une
manière de les informer, c'est aussi
finalement de prendre du contenu de truc
qui est publié et de dire dedans ce qui
est vrai et ce qui est pas vrai. Les
informer d'une façon bienveillante, ça
veut dire pas porter de jugement sur
eux. Bien sûr qu'il faut pas porter de
jugement sur les gens, mais ça c'est pas
le problème que des journalistes, c'est
le problème des femmes et des hommes
politiques. Je veux dire, pourquoi la
gauche prend le le mur depuis des années
? Regardez la manière dont a Non, mais
regardez
Benoît Amon.
Ah bah Benoît Amon, lui il s'est pris
même le plancher. Mais regardez la
manière dont on traite l'électorat de
Donald Trump vue de France. C'était
vraiment frappant. Moi ça m'a beaucoup
frappé la la tous les reportages qui
allaient filmer les électeurs de Biden
et les électeurs de Trump. À chaque
fois, les électeurs de Biden, ils
étaient plutôt bien foutus, beau gosse,
ils avaient un raisonnement vachement
rationnel, toujours bien leur masque sur
la bouche et cetera. Les électeurs de
Trump, ils étaient tous à moitié obèses
avec un chapeau de cowboy, euh des des
t-shirts avec des étoiles. Le coup de
l'obésité.
C'est c'est pas ça que je veux dire.
Tous les électeurs de Trump sont pas
obèses avec un chapeau de cowboy et des
t-shirts à étoile. Ils étaient
sélectionnés comme ça pour montrer d'un
côté l'électeur de Trump de de Biden
rationnel qu'on comprend et pour montrer
de l'autre côté l'électeur de Trump qui
du coup devient facile à moquer. Mais
vous avez quasiment la moitié des
Américains qui ont voté pour Trump et
tous les mecs qui ont voté pour Trump ne
ressemblent pas à ça. Et ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est une manière
finalement de regarder avec
bienveillance ce qui est en train de se
passer et de dire on les comprend pas,
regardez ils sont tous irrationnels.
Heureusement qu'il y a les démocrates
qui ont voté pour Biden. Et ça ça va pas
parce qu'en fait ça évite de
s'interroger sur les raisons pour
lesquelles les gens votent pour Trump.
Pas la même chose
et ça évite de s'interroger en France
aussi sur les raisons pour lesquelles
par exemple les gens votent pour
l'extrême droite. Et
pourquoi pourquoi vous présenter les
gilets jaunes à chaque fois ?
D'ailleurs, c'était dégond tout le monde
l'a pas fait, hein. Vous avez des gens
François
Ruffin,
il est allé faire un documentaire avec
les gilets jaunes, il a pris du temps
avec les gilets jaunes, il a traité
médiatiquement avec respect les gilets
jaunes. Vous
percevez que en France, on a essayé
d'influencer l'opinion publique en
présentant les gilets jaunes comme des
attardés, antisémites qui picolent et
qui qui ont des revendications
complètement
foufous. Pourquoi on a on a essayé de
faire ça ? Nous, on connait des gilets
jaunes,
ils sont chefs d'entreprise, ils payent
leurs impôts, ils essayent de faire et
et il
ils peuvent picoler aussi he c'est pas
un défaut fondamentalement mais euh mais
parce que d'une certaine manière ça nous
avec modération
avec modération euh parce que d'une
certaine manière ça nous rassure. Je
pense que le le
ça rassure qui ?
Bah vous dites les journalistes
qui informment les citoyens en
présentant les gilets jaunes comme des
gens qui seraient pas assez éduqués,
ultra violents, antisémites et cetera.
Ça évite de s'interroger sur les raisons
pour lesquelles vous avez des gens qui
sont aussi en colère contre le pouvoir
et contre la société. Ça évite de
s'interroger sur le niveau d'inégalité,
ça évite de s'interroger sur la pauvreté
qui est remp, ça évite de s'interroger
sur le fait que vous avez vraiment des
gens qui sont à 5 € près à la fin du
mois qui arrivent plus à finir leur
mois. ça évite de s'interroger sur tout
ça. Et ce qui était vraiment frappant,
enfin moi ce qui m'a vraiment tué euh
dans la couverture médiatique parfois,
c'était à la fois la couverture
médiatique et même les les réactions des
lecteurs. On apprend vachement en fait
en regardant les les commentaires en en
en bas de page. Il y avait eu tout un
article qui avait été fait, une enquête
là pour le coup, elle avait aussi
vraiment pris le temps de de le faire et
d'aller avec les gilets jaunes de
Florence Obnas dans le monde. Elle avait
pris le temps d'aller et d'enquêter et
de passer du temps avec des gilets
jaunes. Et puis elle expliquait que et
ben oui, il y avait telle activité qui
avait été supprimée ou alors ils avaient
décidé qu'ils pouvaient plus aller au
resto ou alors leur fille qui allait à
l'équitation plus à l'équitation. Et
vous aviez des commentaires qui étaient
ultra violents en dessous où les gens
disaient "Mais alors attendez, pourquoi
il nous embêtent ces gilets jaunes ?
Pourquoi ils râent toute la journée
alors qu'ils ont de quoi aller au
restaurant ? Finalement, ils sont pas à
5 € près par mois. Et je pense qu'en
fait ça témoigne aussi en partie que on
a une précarisation croissante en France
avec l'appauvrissement de toute une
partie de la population qui a peur de
tomber du mauvais côté finalement et le
fait de mettre une espèce de frontière y
compris dans la construction médiatique
très forte entre les gilets jaunes d'une
part et eux qui sont pas loin finalement
d'un point de vue financier d'être au
bord de la situation des gilets jaunes,
ça les rassure parce qu'ils se disent
"Attendez, c'est juste c'est pas nous."
Et d'ailleurs, nous on est plus éduqué,
nous on n'est pas antisémite, nous on
n'est pas violent. Et ça, les médias se
sont vachement nourris. Et ensuite, vous
avez toute une problématique et ça c'est
la problématique euh bolorée si je peux
la résumer comme ça. Vous avez toute la
problématique CS euh qui fait ça aussi
pour alimenter une espèce de de haine,
une espèce de construction médiatique
euh qui essaie aussi de finalement euh
complètement binariser le le le débat
public en en mettant au centre ce qui
serait un espèce de de pôle de
responsabilité, de sagesse, de
progressisme qui serait le macronisme
et puis tout le reste ça serait les
populistes,
les gilets jaunes. on fait cette
construction médiatique là parce qu'en
fait du coup la la seule position qui
serait la la position raisonnable ça
serait Macron au centre et c'est de ça
aussi qu'il faut absolument sortir.
C'est de ça dont il faut absolument
s'échapper et ce qu'il faut réintroduire
bah c'est de la délibération politique,
c'est du débat politique et ça ça
suppose d'avoir des médias de qualité
qui nous informment véritablement sur ce
qui se passe. Bien du courage le la
polémique The Land 7 quand quand alors
on est ni pro, ni contre ni pour ni ni
contre, on voit le le l'intelligencia
journalistique,
je vais être vulgaire encore, je suis
désolé, défoncer le professeur Raou en
disant voilà The Land 7 a sorti, la
parole de Dieu est arrivée sur terre,
vous vous rendez bien compte, le pépère
avec sa bague tête de mort, il racontait
que n'importe quoi et puis après ils se
sont rendus compte Je dirais pas que
vous avez une bag de tête de mort mais
j'ai noté tout à l'heure.
Mais vous avez pas vu ce qu'il y a
marqué dessus ?
Non, j'étais pas assez prêt.
D'accord. Donc le The Land 7 a a fait de
la merde.
Ouais.
repris en cœur par l'intelligence
journalistique pour dire voilà vous
rendez bien compte les gens qui sont
pour les hydrocorxikin c'est à peu près
les mêmes jeux que les gilets jaunes
c'est c'est demeuré
et après ils sont retrouvés bien dans la
merde le coule pas il a été bien il a
peut-être pas été bien ils ont fait
leur il pas il bah non pas vraiment il a
pas été assez visible en tout cas le mec
cou pas sur Raou c'est un cas
extrêmement intéressant enfin c'est je
je je c'est un cas en plus que que je
connais d'autant mieux que j'ai vécu
longtemps à Marseille j'ai encore toute
une partie de ma famille à Marseille et
que du coup à Marseille c'est C'est
c'est pas faux de dire qu'il y a une
relation assez particulière avec avec
Didier Raout et et vous aviez pour le
coup à Marseille des des fils de gens
qui pouvaient se faire tester, qui
pouvaient se faire soigner par
l'hydroxychloroin et vous aviez un
message qui était rassurant avec un type
qui voulait bosser. Après, est-ce qu'il
a menti ou pas sur l'hydroxychloroine ?
Ce qui est vraiment bizarre avec Raoul,
c'est qu'il est sorti à un moment de sa
position de médecin. En fait, je pense
qu'il a pris la grosse tête médiatique
pour être tout à fait honnête et qu'il a
vu toutes ses caméra penché vers lui et
qui s'est mis à faire de la politique.
Et à partir du moment où il s'est mis à
faire de la politique, il est tombé dans
les mêmes travers que beaucoup de
politiques. Pour répondre sur le land 7.
Sur le land 7, c'était vraiment frappant
parce que pour le coup, je vous disais
tout à l'heure, je suis pas
scientifique, j'ai pas fait de sciences
dures. Par contre, j'ai fait des
sciences sociales, donc j'ai fait un
tout petit peu de stat. Et il y avait un
problème avec les stats. Il suffisait de
la regarder de près quand cette publie
est sortie. J'ai commencé à la regarder
et on est quand même un certain nombre,
c'est de dire bah tiens, on va quand
même la lire cette publication et voir
ce qu'il y a dedans. On s'apercevait
bien qu'il y avait des problèmes et ça
ça fait un mal terrible. Ça fait un mal
un au journalisme, au médias, ça fait un
mal à la science. Si on peut plus faire
confiance aux revues scientifiques qui
sont ce qu'on appelle dans la profession
des revues à comité de lecture, si on
peut plus faire confiance aux revues
scientifique sur des problématiques
comme celles de la COVID, c'est-à-dire
sur des problématiques sur lesquelles on
n'est pas informé et on a besoin
d'information. Quand on parle à la
limite d'économie, c'est pour ça que je
vous dis l'économie c'est pas une
science dure, c'est une science sociale.
Et sur le chômage finalement sur euh sur
sur l'Europe, sur la monnaie unique, on
peut tous avoir une opinion comme
citoyen, une opinion éclairée. On peut
avoir un avis qui est propre sur un truc
comme un vaccin, est-ce que ça marche ou
pas ? On peut pas avoir d'avis qui est
propre. On a besoin, c'est le propre des
sciences dures, de faire confiance à la
science. Et ça, c'est ce qui s'est passé
autour du landet, ça a fait énormément
énormément énormément de mal. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est ça qui permet ensuite
à des documentaires comme Holdup euh
d'être financé sans problème par des par
des campagnes de financement
participatif.
On va passer un peu à l'économie
maintenant. Vous voulez voir ce qu'il y
a marqué dessus ? Gardez ça pour vous
parce que non non le le Je sais qu'on on
a le même accent en anglais. Le
le mien est pas génial. Ouais,
vous gardez ça pour vous.
OK,
on est bon. Ouais, c'est pas mal.
Je dis à tout le monde, elle est pas
cassée.
Donc on va passer à l'économie.
Ouais.
Donc l'économie c'est pas c'est pas une
science.
Non. Pas c'est une science sociale.
C'est pas c'est pas une science. C'est
pas plus une science que l'histoire.
C'est pas plus une science que les
sciences politiques. C'est pas plus une
science que la sociologie. C'est
vraiment ça que je veux souligner. Il y
a plein de gens qui qui font croire mais
ça c'est un c'est un vrai problème de
l'économie de l'économie comme on la
pratique. Alors moi je la pratique pas
comme ça. Donc il y a plein de gens qui
disent que je suis pas une vraie
économiste. Il me mettent plutôt du côté
des sciences politiques à limite je
trouve pas que ça serait un reproche.
Euh mais il y a en fait l'économie la
différence avec d'autres sciences
sociales, c'est que pendant longtemps,
elle a voulu reposer sur les maths. Et
vous avez toute une école de l'économie
française qui est une école de
l'économie française qui fait des maths.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'en fait ça rassurer
les économistes de dire "Nous on fait
des maths, donc on est du côté de la
science dure et on a des modèles, on a
des modèles théoriques parce qu'on a des
modèles où on aurait la vérité et ça
c'est la grande erreur de l'économie
parce qu'un modèle théorique faut écrire
tout et n'importe quoi. Ça dépend des
hypothèses que vous mettez dedans. Et du
coup, moi je pense que c'est urgent de
sortir l'économie de cette illusion de
on est une science, on est une science
dure et de la remettre à sa place,
c'est-à-dire du côté des sciences social
avec la socio, avec les sciences
politiques, avec l'histoire et qui a une
manière de de d'apporter un éclairage
sur le monde, de déconstruire le monde
et puis d'apporter aussi de de la
construction de données, des faites et
des propositions de réforme parfois.
On va rentrer dans le dur.
La crise économique qui se profile
devant nous, ça va être plutôt
cataclysme, plutôt tsunami, plutôt
tempête avec des boules de feu. Ça va
être comment du sang dans les rues.
Bah, elle se profile pas, on est déjà
dedans.
Elle va Ouais, ça va s'accélérer. On est
déjà dedans. Là, vous avez déjà toute
une partie de la population qui est
ultra précarisée. Vous avez eu une
augmentation du chômage, vous avez eu
une augmentation de la pauvreté et ça va
continuer. Euh l'économie, c'est pas une
science et alors c'est encore moins une
science prédictive. l'état de l'économie
dans 6 mois, je peux d'autant moins vous
le dire maintenant qu'on sait pas demain
quand l'économie va redémarrer. On sait
pas
pour aller où ?
Bah non, mais redémarrer simplement en
terme de nombre d'emploi. C'està-dire
que aujourd'hui vous avez un certain
nombre de personnes qui ne peuvent plus
exercer leur activité. Euh les
restaurants sont fermés, les bars sont
fermées, les salles de sport sont
fermées, vous avez tout un nombre de
secteurs qui sont complètement fermés
avec des gens qui du coup alors sont
soit au chômage partiel pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux, soit sont des
étudiants qui ont plus de boulot euh
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils faisaient des
petits boulots, soit euh des
travailleurs qui travaillaient au black
parce qu'on leur a pas donné de papier,
ils ont pas le droit de euh de
travailler euh et en France d'avoir des
papiers alors qu'ils font un boulot qui
sert absolument pour tout le monde. Tous
ces gens-là aujourd'hui, ils sont sur le
carreau. Alors, on a mis en place un
certain nombre de de de de de tampons de
protection, ce qui marche très bien
d'ailleurs pour les travailleurs
salariés, les gens en CDI, c'est-à-dire
que le chômage partiel, ça a très bien
marché en France et ça, on peut s'en
féliciter. Sauf qu'en fait, ce dont on
s'aperçoit, c'est que et là, on en
revient peut-être à Benoît Amont, c'est
que le chômage partiel, c'est bien pour
les gens qui ont un job en CDI et que
tous les gens qui sont
auto-entrepreneurs, vous savez, toutes
les l'économie de de Super tech, chacun
et son propre patron à la Emmanuel
Macron, bah en fait, eux, ils sont pas
du tout protégés. il se retrouve
aujourd'hui sur le carreau. Donc là, il
y a une précarisation euh absolument euh
croissante. Ensuite, euh par rapport à
ça, du coup, je peux pas faire de
prédiction parce que tout ce qui est
café, barre, restaurant, tout ça, on
sait pas quand ça va rouvrir, si ça va
être ouvrir dans 20 janvier, le 20
février, dans 6 mois, si ça va refermer
entre-temps. Et ça, ça va nous dire le
nombre de faillites, euh le nombre de
gens euh qui vont pas réussir à payer
leurs loyers. Quand on dit les loyers,
c'est les beaux commerciaux, mais c'est
aussi les loyers
là où ils vivent, c'est pas le nombre de
gens qui vont se retrouver à la rue.
Donc ça va être horrible. Ça, on sait
très bien. Je veux dire à côté les les
jeunes, ça aurait été une toute petite
secousse. La question c'est comment on
le gère ? J'ai peur qu'on ait pas
aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui soit
suffisamment intelligent pour
reconnaître ses erreurs de début de
mandat qui ont été de faire des énormes
cadeaux riches à commencer par des
cadeaux fiscaux et qui diraient écoutez
j'ai fait ça en 2017 dans un contexte
particulier c'était une erreur ou alors
limite ils peuvent même dire c'était pas
une erreur c'était le bon moment mais
maintenant on a vraiment besoin de faire
de la redistribution parce que pour le
coup avec tout la monnaie qui ont été
qui a été imprimée et toute la relance
qui a été fait pour les banques
centrales là la bourse elle a explosé je
il y a des liquid liquidité. Dans les
banques, il y a des liquidités. Vous
avez vraiment des gens qui ont gagné du
côté financier, vous avez vraiment des
gens qui ont gagné de l'argent. Les
inégalités, elles ont explosé. Il faut
faire de la redistribution. Si on a
l'intelligence de faire de la
redistribution, de la relance par la
redistribution, de la relance par
l'inflation salariale, on pourra s'en
sortir plutôt bien. Le problème, c'est
qu'avec le gouvernement actuel, on est
plutôt parti pour laisser les inégalités
augmenter et on risque d'aller vraiment
droit dans le mur.
Là, on dit que toutes ces mesures
tampon, ça a créé un phénomène
d'entreprise zombie.
C'est quoi une entreprise zombie ?
Bah une entreprise zombie, c'est une
entreprise qui continue à exister sur le
papier alors qu'elle a plus de véritable
activité économique. Donc vous prenez un
restaurant par exemple, vous mettez les
salariés au chômage partiel, le chômage
partiel est payé en partie par l'État.
Vous avez du temps euh pour payer les
loyers, des reports de loyer, vous avez
des reports de charge. Donc votre
restaurant, il peut continuer à exister
alors qu'il a plus d'activité
économique. C'est une entreprise zombie
parce qu'on est dans une économie
zombie, ça marcherait pas si ce resto il
pouvait avoir son activité complètement
normale ou le bar son activité
complètement normale et il préférait
finalement ne rien faire, toucher des
aides et les gens restaient chez eux et
toucher le chômage partiel. Là ça marche
et c'est quand même pas mal qu'on ait ça
parce que sinon vous allez tuer toute
une partie du de tout un p du secteur
d'activité des du savoir du savoir-faire
mettre des gens sur le carreau alors
qu'en fait les gens veulent faire leur
boulot. Ils sont là pour faire leur
boulot. En plus il y a une demande
c'estàd il y a une offre il y a une
demande truc basique de l'économie juste
en fait on laisse pas pour le coup
l'offre et la demande se rencontrer
puisqu'on a forcé les entreprises à être
fermées. Donc là c'est plutôt bien en
fait qu'on les ait mis en position de
zombie. Le problème c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'entre eux qui risquent
de pas se relever.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des marchés
financiers, des agences de notation ?
Est-ce que les agences de notation,
c'est un peu comme les journalistes,
c'est-à-dire que ils sont payés par un
tel, donc ils donnent à peu près telle
note ? Est-ce que c'est fiable ?
Bah, le problème des agences de notation
pour le coup, c'est le leur modèle
économique. Euh non, mais c'est vrai, il
y a un véritable problème de de modèle
économique. On pourrait avoir des
agences de notation. Ben, exactement,
mais ça va avec. C'est-à-dire que vous
avez des agences de notation qui vont
être payées euh par des boîtes pour les
noter.
Donc c'est les boîtes qui pai Non mais
justement c'est ça qui est intéressant.
à la base, c'est
à la base, c'est les boîtes qui payent
les agences de notation pour les noter.
Et les agences de notation vont noter
aussi les États. Et c'est en notant les
États finalement que les agences de
notation vont se faire une réputation
pour avoir des clients du côté des
boîtes. Ce qui veut dire que en fait,
elles vont avoir tendance à euh noter
finalement les États en changeant les
notes du jour au lendemain pour que tout
le monde dise "Ah, regardez, Mouis, ils
ont changé la note de tel ou tel pays."
Il l'avait fait par exemple sur la
Grèce. Donc tout le monde va parler de
cette agence de notation qui va
apparaître comme une agence sérieuse et
les boîtes vont être davantage prêtes à
payer euh finalement euh pour être noté
par ces agences-là. Il y a un problème
de modèle économique, ça crée des
mauvaises incitations. Mais c'est un peu
près la même chose pour les instituts de
sondage. Souvent, on se dit "Ah mais
pourquoi il y a tant de sondage ?
Pourquoi on narrête pas de dire "Ah ben
alors tel et à tel pourcentage comme
s'il y avait toujours des inversions
dans les courbes de sondage entre les
hommes politiques parce que vous avez
des instituts de sondage qui font des
sondages plus ou moins gratuitement sur
les questions politiques, ce qui leur
permet d'avoir de la visibilité, ce qui
leur permet d'être invité dans les
médias pour commenter ces sondages. Et
pourquoi ils font ça ? Parce que
derrière, comme ils sont visibles, vous
avez des boîtes qui passent commandent
et c'est comme ça qu'ils gagnent leur
argent.
Extraterritorialité du droit américain à
travers le dollar,
ça c'est une vraie question. Mais alors
si on rentre là-dedans, on en est pas on
en est pas sorti. Mais la valeur du
dollar et le poids extrêmement important
du dollar, c'est ça qui fait que les
États-Unis depuis des années peuvent
vivre largement au-dessus de leurs
moyens. C'est un truc qui est
extrêmement intéressant. aux États-Unis,
c'est un pays qui est extrêmement
endetté et qui malgré tout continue à
avoir, si vous regardez euh son la
différence entre les revenus euh qui
touchent de la dette accumulée, enfin
qui doit payer pour la dette accumulée
versus les revenus qui touchent des des
des prêts qu'il a fait, c'est un pays
qui continue à gagner beaucoup parce
qu'on prête à très faible taux aux
États-Unis. Donc, il peut accumuler une
dette financière finalement avec un
effet de boule au cours du temps tout en
gardant cette espèce de stabilité.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils ont de dollar.
On a créé l'euro.
On a créé l'euro contre ça.
Ouais. Alors, ils ont une grosse armée
mais la grosse armée, ça assure pas un
équilibre, une stabilité économique.
Non, mais par contre, ça permet de
répudier sa dette quand c'est inscrit
dans la constitution. Non.
Bah, si vous voulez, demain
la la question des États-Unis pour que
l'équilibre tienne, c'est pas une
question de répudier la dette ou de pas
répudier la dette. La question des
États-Unis, c'est une question de
confiance. Si demain les Chinois,
comment les États-Unis font tourner leur
dette ? cette idée de roulement de la
dette que vous pouvez avoir un
endettement perpétuel. Pourquoi ? Parce
que vous passez votre temps à émettre
des nouveaux emprunts d'État et à chaque
fois vous avez des gens qui sont prêts à
acheter ces nouveaux empreints d'état le
jour où la confiance disparaît et le
jour notamment où la Chine arrête de
financer les États-Unis, c'est même pas
une question de réputation de dette. Ils
peuvent le mettre en faillite de répud
répudier répudiation de dettes. Ils
peuvent le mettre en faillite. C'est
même pas ça fondamentalement le problème
c'est pas que les États-Unis demain vont
dire "Nous, on arrête de payer notre
dette." Ce qui peut se passer, c'est que
demain, ils émettent des bons et puis
personne n'achète les bons et ce
jour-là, vous avez l'économie américaine
qui s'effondre. Le problème c'est que
comme l'économie américaine est
complètement intégrée à l'économie
mondiale, personne n'y a intérêt. Vous
avez vu la crise financière de
2007-2008, c'était une crise américaine
qui a mis l'Europe à genou parce que
cette crise américaine, elle a eu des
répercussions extrêmement fortes sur
tous les pays d'Europe qui avaient bah
des bons, des emprunts aux États-Unis,
des liens très forts avec l'économie
américaine. Et c'est cette intégration
générale finalement de l'économie qui
fait que personne n'a intérêt à ce que
les États-Unis s'effondrent. La question
est-ce qu'on va avoir un jour un pôle
Asie suffisamment fort ? qui fait que
les États-Unis pourront laisser enfin la
Chine pourra laisser les États-Unis
s'effondrer sans prendre le risque d'un
effondrement de la Chine
ou sans prendre le risque d'avoir une
petite guerre
une guerre mondiale entre la Chine et
les États-Unis aujourd'hui bah vous avez
une guerre commerciale
c'est pas
et c'est une guerre relativement apaisée
mais vous pouvez avoir enfin aujourd'hui
on a un président américain qui est un
président complètement fou qui est
encore là jusqu'au 20 janvier personne
n'a peur qu'il aille faire la guerre à
la Chine. Euh le fait que du jour au
lendemain, il décide avant de partir
d'envoyer une bombe nucléaire sur la
Corée du Nord, je veux dire ça ça paraît
complètement irréaliste en en même
temps, il est relativement fou. Euh
alors après, on est tous nourris de
séries. Il y a la série britannique qui
s'appelle Ears ande qui avait fait le
paris que Trump était réélu en en 2020
et qui fait dans son scénario en 2024 le
fait que Trump avant de partir, il
balance alors c'est sur une île à côté
de la Chine, c'est pas sur la Corée du
Nord une bombe nucléaire. Mais vous avez
des tensions extrêmement fortes. En en
vérité aujourd'hui, les tensions
militaires les plus fortes euh c'est pas
entre la Chine et les États-Unis, c'est
entre la Chine et l'Inde.
Et tout ça, bien sûr qu'il faut le
regarder euh de près. pour l'eau.
Bah, vous avez des questions autour
d'eau, vous avez des questions de
territorialité, vous avez des questions
simplement de montrer les muscles en
Inde. Vous avez quand même aujourd'hui
Maudit qui est premier ministre, qui est
pas le premier des démocrates et
notamment dans la manière dont il a
traité les musulmans et donc il continue
à traiter les musulmans qui veut
s'affirmer et dans sa manière de
s'affirmer sur la scène internationale,
il va il va s'opposer il va s'opposer de
manière très forte au Chinois.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de le fait du
fait que l'Arabie Saoudite paye ses
dividendes à crédit ?
C'est c'est ça fait partie du problème
et il y a tellement de problèmes qui
entourent aujourd'hui la question de de
l'Arabie Saoudite que il faudrait
reprendre et tout reconstruire du début.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez des empires
pétroliers, vous avez des pays qui ont
accumulé des ressources pétrolières
telles que ces pays possèdent des actifs
un peu partout dans le monde. C'est des
pays qui ne produisent rien, sauf du
pétrole. Et entre vous et moi, le
pétrole, on ferait mieux de le laisser
sous la terre que de le consommer parce
que c'est ça qui contribue aussi au
réchauffement de la planète. Ça crée des
tensions internationales et régionales
extrêmement importantes. Euh ça explique
une explosion des inégalités. Alors pour
le coup, plus seulement à l'intérieur
des pays, mais entre les pays
extrêmement importantes. Et vous avez
finalement ces pays qui aujourd'hui ont
des ressources surdimensionnées qui fait
qu'on leur accorde un poids politique
sur la scène internationale également
surdimensionné. Euh il faut s'interroger
sur tout ça. Euh il faut s'interroger
sur ces questions au niveau
international, il faut aussi
s'interroger sur ces questions au niveau
euh national. Euh c'est pas normal que
vous ayez euh dans un pays aujourd'hui
comme la France un certain nombre
d'immeubles entiers qui soient possédés
euh par des monarchies pétrolières qui
soient complètement vites parce que vous
avez eu de l'accumulation d'actifs quand
en même temps euh quand vous avez des
migrants qui mettent des tentes sur la
place de la République, ils sont expés
par les flics manu military et avec
beaucoup de violence. Euh, il faut
s'interroger sur tout ça. On s'est on
s'est mis dans un espèce de nouvel
équilibre géopolitique nous, on se
satisfait comme s'il était la norme,
sauf qu'il est pas du tout euh
satisfaisant. Ensuite, c'est des
questions qui sont extrêmement
complexes. Moi, c'est pas ma spécialité.
C'est plus des trucs sur lesquels je
peux on peut en discuter de citoyen
citoyen. C'est-à-dire que je vais vous
dire ce que j'ai lu dans les journaux
euh et en plus vous vous en savez sans
doute plus que moi. Euh mais c'est des
trucs qui me rassurent pas et surtout en
tout cas c'est des trucs sur l'équilibre
actuel des choses ne me convient pas. Le
problème c'est que c'est des questions
sur lesquelles la plupart des politiques
ne s'expriment pas. il rentrent pas dans
ces problématiques là, soit parce
qu'elles sont trop compliquées, soit
parce qu'il les trouvent pas sexy sur la
scène internationale. Pay des
fouillardes. Non,
ça faut quand même pas pousser. J'ai
j'ai j'ai pas cette vision si négative
de tout le personnel politique, mais
c'est sans doute vrai pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux.
On s'est toujours sorti de de crise
économique par une augmentation de
consommation énergétique.
C'est pas faux.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer là ?
Bah, va falloir qu'on apprenne à faire
le contraire. Mais il y a une
possibilité pour le coup avec l'énergie
là. Il y a des possibilités
d'investissement qui sont extrêmement
importantes parce qu'il faut qu'on
apprenne à faire de l'énergie autrement.
Falloir qu'on on apprenne à en consommer
moins. Mais ça, on sait pas encore
faire. Euh si on somme moins, on va on
va rester dans la crise économique.
Non, justement, il faut qu'on apprenne à
la produire différemment. Et c'est là où
il y a des des possibilités
d'investissement. Aujourd'hui, quand on
consomme du pétrole, en fait, ça fait
augmenter nos importations, ça nous
coûte plutôt cher et en plus ça pollue
la planète. Si on est capable de faire
de l'éolien, si on est capable de faire
de l'énergie solaire, si on est capable
d'innover de ce point de vue-là, on peut
créer des possibilités de croissance, on
peut créer des possibilités d'emploi et
on crée aussi du coup des possibilités
de consommation. Je pense qu'il faut
aussi qu'on s'interroge sur la manière
dont on consomme. De toute façon, il va
falloir qu'on s'interroge sur la manière
dont on consomme. Et de toute façon,
enfin, finalement, vous et moi, moi ça
me frappe vachement euh je me suis
jamais senti aussi vieille que ces
dernières années parce que j'avais
plutôt l'impression
Ouais. justement, j'avais plutôt
l'impression d'être jeune et de gauche.
Et puis quand vous voyez toute la
génération qui arrive derrière qui a 15
ans, 16 ans, 17 ans et qui a 17 ans et
tant mieux d'ailleurs, en fait c'est eux
qui ont raison. S'achète plus de
téléphone, çaète plus de fringue, çaète
plus du tout de de fringue neuves,
refuse de prendre l'avion et cetera.
C'est pas des gens qui se disent il faut
absolument être dans la décroissance ou
au chômage. C'est des gens qui prendent
prennent à bras le corps euh la question
du changement de climatique et qui
prennent à bras le corps toutes ces
questions-là et qui prennent à bras le
corps le fait de faire de l'agriculture
différemment et qui vont choisir de
passer une partie de leur temps, de
leurs vacances et cetera euh à aller
créer des champs, des fermes
collectives, faire les choses
différemment. Ça va bouger grâce à cette
génération là. Ce qu'il faut faire pour
le coup, c'est cette génération là la
faire monter au pouvoir un tout petit
peu plus vite et pas attendre qu'elle
est 50 ans et qu'elle soit déjà devenue
vieille.
Question internet. Peut-on lui parler du
revenu universel ?
Bah ouais.
C'est quoi le revenu universel ?
Bah le revenu universel ça ça peut
vouloir dire tout et et n'importe quoi
parce que c'est une idée qui a été
défendue à la fois par les ultra
libéraux à la Gaspar Kening qui veulent
supprimer entièrement l'État et puis par
les gens les plus à gauche du spectre
politique. Donc moi je vais vous parler
de celui que que je défends. Il se
trouve qu'en 2017 j'ai fait la campagne
comme économiste de Benoît Amont qui
avait mis au centre de sa campagne cette
idée de revenu universel. Pourquoi
l'idée de revenu universel ? C'est
l'idée de donner à tous les Français un
revenu de base et un revenu de base
garanti qui est donné automatiquement.
Je vais pas dire qu'il avait vu venir la
crise sanitaire, mais ce qu'il avait
assez vu bien vu venir, c'est c'est le
fait que aujourd'hui les protections
sociales qui existent, qui datent de
1945, finalement sont plus adaptées au
système actuel. Ça marche très bien dans
un système de salariat où vous avez le
le chômage, vous avez tout qui est de
manière faite, de manière extrêmement
lisse au cours du temps, mais ça marche
pas pour les carrières heurté, ça marche
pas pour les pour les plus précaires,
pour les gens qui rentrent, qui sortent
dans l'emploi, qui sont pas en CDI pour
toute leur vie. Pour ces gens-là
aujourd'hui, vous avez des protections
qui sont difficiles à obtenir en terme
de temps, en terme de connaissance, en
terme de savoir. Aujourd'hui, si vous
voulez avoir le RSA en France, c'est pas
automatique. C'est-à-dire que si vous
avez plus de revenu en France
aujourd'hui et que vous avez le droit au
RSA, vous recevez pas automatiquement le
RSA. Il faut aller faire une demande du
RSA, faut aller au guichet, faut
satisfaire un certain nombre de
conditions régulièrement. Vous allez
perdre le RSA au passage. Et d'ailleurs,
c'est pour ça que vous avez plein de
gens qui vont pas demander leur RSA. Et
ça c'est extrêmement problématique parce
qu'en plus ceux qui le demandent le
moins euh ce sont souvent ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin et les plus
précaires. Et donc l'idée de dire
c'était que en fait on veut quoi ? On
veut protéger y compris les plus
précaires de manière automatique. Donc
faisons en sorte que on ait 500 600 700
€ par mois. On peut discuter du montant
qui soit donné à tous les Français
chaque mois de manière automatique quand
ils sont en dessous de ce revenu là. Et
c'est ça qu'on appelle le revenu
universel. C'est l'automaticité d'un
revenu de base qui fait qu'on ne laisse
personne dans la misère, personne dans
la précarité et que comme citoyen, quand
on se réveille le matin, qu'on se
regarde dans la glace, on peut se
regarder un petit peu en face.
C'est quoi les critiques du revenu
universel ?
Bah, il y en a eu plusieurs. Enfin, bah
si je vous raconte en la la campagne de
de Benoît Amon, on s'est fait aussi un
peu taper là-dessus. Benoît Amon, il a
il avait fait toute sa campagne des
primaires en disant "On va donner le
revenu universel à tout le monde."
C'estàd y compris si vous gagnez 1
million d'euros, 2 million d'euros, 10
millions d'euros par mois, vous aurez
votre chèque de 500 €. C'est
complètement universel de ce point de
vue-là. ce qui posait pas mal de
problèmes, notamment le fait que si vous
faites ça en fait artificiellement vous
allez dépenser beaucoup, donc augmenter
beaucoup les impôts et prendre de la
main droite à quelqu'un euh pour lui
redonner de la main gauche. Bon et quand
on je suis rentré notamment euh dans la
campagne après la victoire des des
primaires, on s'est dit "Attendez, on
peut avoir le revenu universel, mais si
le revenu universel vous pouvez pas le
donner à quelqu'un qui gagne plus de
3000 ou 4000 € par mois, mais ça sert à
rien de lui donner pour lui retirer
ensuite." Donc on a développé toute une
conception de revenu universel qui
revenait à dire bah le revenu universel,
il sera donné automatiquement en même
temps que la feuille de salaire. Et si
vous avez pas de salaire, il vous sera
donné automatiquement mais au-delà d'un
certain montant, vous le toucherez pas.
C'est quoi les autres ?
Et du coup une critique qui a été portée
à ça, c'était de dire "Ah mais si on
fait ça, c'est plus vraiment universel."
Bah si, c'est vraiment universel. euh
parce qu'en fait tous les gens qui en
ont besoin l'ont l'ont automatiquement
et l'ont sans en refaire la demande. Et
si je devais reporter une version du
revenu universel demain, je reporterai
cette version du revenu universel. Là,
c'est un complément de salaire qui vous
est donné sur votre feuille de paix
quand vous travaillez et ça c'est
extrêmement important. J'ai fait
beaucoup pour le coup de meeting,
beaucoup de rencontres, je suis beaucoup
allé en province. Je faisais une
campagne électorale, vous faites une
campagne électorale, vous allez parler
aux gens et c'est tant mieux, ça vous
rend beaucoup moins con et on devrait le
faire beaucoup plus souvent. Bah vous
savez qui c'était en face ? C'était
François Fillon en face ou c'était
Emmanuel Macron en face ou c'était
Marine Le Pen en face ? Donc à
l'arrivée, c'était quand même mieux de
se battre pour Benoît Amont que pour
Fillon, que pour Macron ou que pour Le
Pen. Ensuite, il y a la question et je
je passe pas à côté de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon. Quand on a commencé la
campagne avec Benoît Amont, Benoît Amont
il était à 17 18 % dans les sondages et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, il était à 9 10 %
dans les sondages.
Ah bah alors, je peux vous sortir, je
sais pas qui fait des sondages en
France. problème en plus de des
journalistes, il y a pas un problème
avec les sondages ?
Ah bah si, c'est ce que je vous souligné
tout à l'heure sur les agences de
notation. On a un problème de sondage,
on publie trop de sondages, on publie
les sondages sans euh écart-types, ce
qui fait qu'on passe notre temps à
commenter des sondages et notamment des
variations dans les sondages tel et
passé devant tel autre alors qu'en fait
c'est pas significatif d'un point de vue
statistique. Il faudrait moins
Mélenchon. Alors on mélon si on prend la
question de Mélenchon et Mélenchon était
le premier à le reconnaître à ce
moment-là. Mélenchon anticipait pas que
Benoît Amont gagne la première des
socialistes. Il l'anticipait pas.
Pensait que ça serait un Manuel Vals. Et
si ça avait été Manuel Vals, il avait un
boulevard. Et si ça avait été Manuel
Vals, je serais allé faire la campagne
de Mélenchon. Enfin, je dis ça. Il
aurait peut-être pas absolument pas
voulu de moi dans sa campagne, il
faudrait lui demander. En tout cas,
j'aurais voté pour Mélenchon et j'aurais
certainement pas fait la campagne de
Vals. Ça a pas été le cas.
Vous avez voté pour Macron au deuxème
tour ? Ouais, j'ai voté pour Macron au
2e tour et je vais même dire pire que
ça, si on se retrouve encore avec Macron
face à Le Pen, je revoterai pour Macron
au 2è tour, même si je m'oppose très
fortement tous les jours en permanence à
la politique de Macron, même si je pense
que ce qu'il fait est extrêmement
dangereux, même si j'ai de plus en plus
de mal finalement à voir la différence
notamment sur des problématiques comme
la loi sécurité globale entre Macron et
ce que proposerait une droite dure. Je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore une
vraie différence entre les partis
républicains et l'extrême droite et je
me battrai toujours contre le
Rassemblement national. Ensuite comme
citoyenne, bah on disait tout à l'heure,
j'ai 36 ans, c'est veut dire que j'ai eu
18 ans en 2002. Donc la première fois
que j'ai voté, c'est en 2002. La
première fois que j'ai voté, j'ai voté
j'ose pas. A priori, on n'était pas
assez nombreux. Mais moi, j'ai un talent
comme ça. En général, je vote toujours
pour les candidats qui qui perdent. Donc
personne va vouloir que je fasse la
campagne en 2022. Mais j'ai voté pour
Josepin. La deuxième fois dans mon
deuxième vote dans la vie, bah j'ai dû
voter pour Cherak. Bon, ça me faisait
pas vraiment plaisir la donc en fait la
deuxième fois que j'ai voté dans ma vie
comme citoyenne, j'ai dû voter contre.
Paf, j'ai redou le faire en 2017.
Franchement, la dernière chose dont j'ai
envie en 2022, c'est devoir revoter
contre. J'aimerais bien voter pour un
candidat qui a un programme
satisfaisant. Et le problème
aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on a pas d'union à
gauche. Pourquoi ne pas voter ?
Parce que moi, je crois aux élections,
je crois à la démocratie. Je pense qu'il
faut renforcer les droits des citoyens.
Voyez, je veux faire des citoyens, des
actionnaires de mé ça fait partie de la
démocratie. Vote vot blanc. Ah, par
contre, je suis pour euh bah si j'étais
au pouvoir et je devais faire une
réforme des institutions, je rendrai un
le vote obligatoire, deux je
comptabiliserai le vote blanc. Je pense
qu'il faut faire les deux à la fois.
Faut que les gens aient voté, mais il
faut qu'on prenne en compte le fait de
dire "Je suis pas satisfait euh par
l'offre politique. Euh je choisis de pas
euh ne pas voter quand c'est Macron
versus Le Pen parce que j'ai quand même
peur que Le Pen passe et que je veux
m'assurer que Le Pen passe pas parce que
je pense qu'on aura rien de pire en
France que le Pen qui passe." Alors
après, on peut dire ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur les médias qu'en fait
comme ça, on aura vraiment touché le
fond et qu'ensuite on pourra redémarrer
et reconstruire. Mais si on repense pour
le coup aux années 30, fait d'avoir
touché le fond, ça a quand même été un
tout petit peu coûteux et moi j'ai pas
du tout envie de prendre ce risque-là.
J'aimerais bien quand même qu'on ait pas
la gauche la plus courte du monde. Euh
je Non mais je pense qu'en 2017 de toute
façon la responsabilité elle est des
deux côtés hein. Elle est du côté de
Mélenchon comme de Amon. Je pense qu'il
y aurait dû avoir un moment dans la
campagne où les deux candidats se
mettaient ensemble. Alors ça a été un
truc d'O envie de dire ça a été un truc
de mec. Je pense ça a été un peu un truc
de mec. C'est-à-dire que au tout départ
quand Amon gagne il est à 18 dans les
sondages. Mélenchon est à 10. Et à ce
moment-là, Amon dit à Mélenchon, "Bah
retire-toi, viens avec moi." Après, un
moment, ça s'inverse et Mélenchon dit à
Amon : "Bah, retire-toi, viens avec
moi." Et c'est vrai que c'est absurde à
l'arrivée. C'est absurde d'avoir
Mélenchon qui passe pas au second tour
alors qu'Amon est à 6 % des voix. À
l'arrivée comme citoyen, on se dit tous
"Bon bah en fait, le jour dans les
urnes, j'aurais dû voter Mélenchon parce
que c'était lui qui était tout en haut."
Mais la problématique, c'est qu'on
devrait pas déterminer tout ça par des
sondages. Vous dites que les sondages
c'est con. Où est les sondages c'est con
? Et c'est pour ça que moi je crois
alors tout le monde trouve que ça fait
très conservateur, je crois au primaire,
je crois au débat d'idée. Je crois
qu'entre Amont et Mélenchon, ça aurait
dû jouer dans une primaire au débat
d'idée. Et celui qu'il aurait emporté au
vote parmi tous les gens qui allaient
voter pour la gauche, il y serait allé,
il y serait allé seul, il serait passé
au second tour et du coup, on aurait
voté pour. En en tout cas, moi j'aurais
voté pour.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du plan de
relance européen ?
Bah alors déjà, le plan de relance
européen, il a toujours pas été voté.
Enfin, il Non, c'est un truc de fou.
Non, mais c'était un c'était un très bon
coup de com. Euh ça pose énormément de
problèmes. Alors, on pourrait en parler
de de pendant très longtemps. Il y a des
trucs qui sont bien sur le fait d'avoir
une dette commune au niveau de l'Europe,
c'est très bien. On aurait dû le faire
depuis longtemps. Donc ça ça a été une
avancée et ça a été une bonne chose.
Ensuite, la mise en scène, il y a
beaucoup de problèmes. Il y a un
problème sur la mise en scène. Alors, le
fait de nous créer des conciliabulles de
chefs d'état dont on nous fait croire
qu'il travaille très très dur tout toute
la nuit. Vous savez moi sérieux euh
quand j'ai des étudiants qui me qui
m'écrivent en disant j'ai fini ce truc à
5h du matin en général c'est pas
vraiment eux que je prends le plus au
sérieux quoi. Je me dis bah ouais en
fait non tu t'organises, tu finis pas à
5h du matin. Les chefs d'État, ils
veulent nous faire un peu le même truc
quoi. Ouais pendant 3 jours, on n pas
dormi, on a été jour et nuit en train de
négocier pour obtenir un accord au bout
du compte. On se dit avec tous leurs
conseillers quand même, ils auraient
quand même pu trouver l'accord un peu
avant. Ouais, il faut justifier son
salaire. Et surtout, il faut il faut
créer une espèce d'attente médiatique
autour d'un résultat assez incertain.
Donc à la place d'avoir un truc qui
était un endettement commun européen qui
aurait pu être une très bonne chose,
adopté de manière démocratique par une
assemblée européenne qui aurait fait un
vote démocratique sur cette questionlà,
il faut refonder les institutions
européennes autour de ça. On a quoi ? On
a ce conciliabul de chef d'état où on
nous fait croire qu'on a un accord qui
ne marche pas à l'arrivée. Ça a toujours
pas été voté aujourd'hui parce que quoi
? Vous avez le véto
Hongrie parce qu'on a aujourd'hui une
Union européenne qui marche et pour le
coup on marche sur la tête à la règle de
l'unanimité et pas à la règle du tout de
la majorité. Alors on pourrait dire il
faut la majorité qualifiée, pas la
majorité simple mais ça marche à
l'unanimité. Donc on a ce truc qui date
de cet été. On nous a dit c'est une
révolution au niveau européen. Là on est
en décembre, ça a toujours pas été
adopté. l'argent est toujours pas là
alors que les pays européens s'enfoncent
les uns après les autres dans la crise.
Donc si ça avait été bien fait, ça
aurait pu être bien. Moi, je suis pour
avoir une dette commune au niveau
européen et qu'on puisse émettre de la
dette ensemble, c'est le principe même
de la solidarité. C'est ce qui permet
aux Allemands et aux Français qui
empreintent pas cher de filer un coup de
main aux Espagnols et aux Italiens qui
empreintent beaucoup plus cher sur le
marché européen. Donc en soit d'aide
commune européenne, c'est bien. En soit
plan de relance européen, c'est bien. La
manière dont ça a été fait, ça a été une
catastrophe et je pense que ça
décrédibilise encore plus sur le long
terme les institutions européennes.
La dislocation géopolitique européenne
et mondiale. On va prendre l'exemple du
Brexit. C'est quoi le Brexit ? C'est
chacun son cuidé dieu pour tous. C'est
salut les gars, c'est on fait quoi ?
Non, bah le Brexit en en partie c'est
mon autre dada, mon autre centre
d'intérêt, la question du financement de
la vie politique. Euh je dis ça parce
que pour le coup les financements de la
campagne dans le Brexit, on a parlé
beaucoup du scandale Cambridge
Analytica, on a parlé beaucoup des fake
news, on a parlé beaucoup du fait que
les gens qui étaient pour le Brexit
avaient payé pour avoir des bus qui qui
vraiment tramalaient des fake news
puisque les fake news étaient imprimés
sur sur les bus. C'est ça qui a fait
basculer une partie des lectorats. Donc
je pense que
en fait ça pose quoi comme question
avant de parler géopolitique, parlons
politique. Il y a la question du
référendum. Je pense que le référendum
c'est un bon outil et je pense que le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne c'est
un bon outil. Tout à l'heure, on parlait
des gilets jaunes. Je pense qu'il
faudrait mettre en France en place un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne. Ça me
paraît indispensable et ça me paraît
même nécessaire. Sauf que simplement le
référendum, ça suffit pas. Si vous
faites croire aux gens "Ah ben vous avez
cette possibilité de dire oui" non crois
plus au référendum maintenant le dans le
Non non alors on peut parler du de
maschich on va y revenir mais là on
parlait du Brexit dans le cas du Brexit
les gens ils ont cru qu'on les informait
bien et qu'on leur donnait la
possibilité de faire un choix ils ont
voté ensuite ils sont aperçus qu'on les
avait désinformé donc dès le lendemain
ils ont dit "Attendez il faut refaire le
vote où on nous a désinformé". Bah en
fait il aurait déjà fallu euh encadrer
avant les financements de la campagne
pour éviter qu'on puisse désinformer les
citoyens. Premier truc. Deuxième truc,
référendum, on leur a fait croire que
c'était une question binaire et on a dit
aux gens, "Est-ce que vous voulez sortir
ou rester ?" Que gens ont dit sortir. Et
puis après, on s'est aperçu que c'était
pas une question binaire. C'est pas
comme si vous là, vous ouvriez la porte
et vous sortez. Là, vous sortez de la
pièce. Vous direz on vote, vous restez,
vous sortez pas, vous sortez de la
pièce. Vous demandez aux gens est-ce
qu'il voulent que je reste, je sors, je
sors de la pièce, c'est fini, c'est
binaire. Le Brexit, c'est pas ça. On va
pas envoyer euh la Grande-Bretagne sur
la planète Mars. Ils sont pas du tout
sortis. Je veux dire, il faut qu'il
reste. Il y a encore des flux humains,
on va pas arrêter les flux humains. Il y
a encore des flux de marchandises, il y
a encore des flux de capitaux. Donc une
fois que vous avez dit "Vous voulez euh
vous voulez le Brexit", comment vous
l'organisez concrètement ? Et là, ça
fait 2 ans qu'ils av qu'ils arrivent pas
à l'organiser parce qu'ils savent pas
vraiment ce qu'ils veulent en terme de
sortie. Donc vous avez fait croire aux
citoyens que vous leur donnez un
pouvoir, celui celui de dire on sort, on
reste et en fait vous vous les avez
plongé dans une énorme incertitude où
ils sont toujours bloqués aujourd'hui.
Mastrich.
Bah, il y a Mastrich mais pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas la c'est pas la la chose
la la plus choquante. Le référendum de
Mastrich, il y a eu un Oui, on est
rentré dans l'euro. Je pense que l'euro
ça reste une bonne chose. Je pense que
la construction européenne dans l'idée,
ça reste une très bonne chose. Je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un problème avec
les institutions européen. Quand les
gens disent non et que
et que et que on leur fait passer le
truc en
Exactement. Le problème c'est pour ça
pour moi, le problème c'est pas
Mastrich. Le problème c'est 2005. En
2005, les gens ont voté non, ils ont
voté contre le changement d'institution
et on l'a fait adopter au parlement. Ça
c'est un scandale démocratique. Comment
voulez-vous que les gens fassent
confiance aux hommes et aux femmes
politiques ? Comment voulez-vous que les
gens aillent voter ? C'est quand ils
votent non à une question qu'on leur
pose.
Ensuite, on fait comme s'ils avaient
voté oui. Ça c'est un problème. 2005 de
toute façon, c'est ça qui a marqué d'une
certaine manière la mort de la relation
entre les citoyens et l'Europe. Et c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut repenser
à zéro la construction des institutions
européennes.
Question internet. Comment fait-elle
pour s'informer objectivement en lisant
uniquement des médias de gauche ? Hm,
j'ai pas uniquement des médias de
gauche. Euh bah déjà parce que ça fait
partie de mon boulot. Enfin, je veux
dire, moi je fais des cours sur les
médias, je fais des cours sur la
démocratie. Donc je lis un peu tout. Euh
je lis aussi régulièrement des médias de
droite. Euh je lis les échos, euh je lis
le Figaro, j'y prends pas de plaisir.
Euh je le lis comme une activité euh
professionnelle. J'ai aussi pas mal de
médias internationaux. Euh moi, je l New
York Times, j'ai le Washington Post. Il
se trouve que je suis à moitié espagnole
et du coup je je parle couramment
espagnol beaucoup mieux que mon anglais
d'ailleurs. Euh et du coup je lis aussi.
Oui oui. Non mais vous notiez mon accent
tout à l'heure et ça m'arrive même alors
là pour le coup c'est quand même un peu
plus dur et un peu plus violent pour moi
mais de passer du temps sur des sites
comme Brightbart et cetera. Euh vous
pouvez pas essayer de comprendre
l'écologie du système médiatique et
essayer de l'enseigner, de l'étudier, de
le décortiquer si vous consommez que les
médias qui vous font plaisir. Donc s'il
y a bien quelqu'un qui doit sortir de de
la bulle médiatique qui correspond à ses
convictions politiques, c'est c'est les
gens qui étudient les médias. Donc
j'essaie de le faire au maximum.
Donc là, il y a il y a c'est pas une
question internet, c'est un commentaire,
mais je vais lire je vais je vais lire
quand même le commentaire. Elle ne veut
pas des journalistes, elle veut elle
veut être fonctionnaire de
l'information. Ah non, c'est pas vrai,
pas moi. Euh enfin, je veux pas de
fonctionnaire de l'information. Il y a
des gens qui ont fait des propositions
dans ce sens-là et d'ailleurs des des
des propositions qui étaient pas
inintéressantes. Pierre Rimbert par
exemple euh le modèle qu'il a proposé
pour les médias avec le monde
diplomatique où il disait justement
qu'il fallait une espèce de grande
agence France-Press et mettre en commun
toute la production de l'information,
mettre en commun toute la distribution
de l'information et derrière simplement
laisser aux rédactions le le fait
d'avoir de de d'apporter leur
subjectivité. Ils voulaient davantage
faire ça. Moi, je veux pas du tout de
fonctionnaire de de l'information. En
fait, je vais vous dire ce que je veux.
Euh je je je réfléchis vachement même
là-dessus. Comment on détient un média ?
Vous avez soit des médias privés, soit
des médias publics. Les médias public,
pour commencer, les journalistes, ils
sont pas fonctionnaires et d'ailleurs,
il faut garantir leur indépendance. Ils
sont salariés de boîtes privées. Euh
France Télévision, c'est une boîte
privée, c'est une société par action qui
est détenue par l'État comme l'été
Orange ou comme l'été plein de boîtes
publiques avant d'être privatisé. Donc
déjà faut le dire, enfin les les les
gens que vous entendez sur la radio
publique ou les journalistes que vous
voyez à la télé publique, ils sont pas
fonctionnaires. Vous avez pas de
journalistes fonctionnaires. Bon, mais
c'est des médias privés détenus par
l'État et ensuite vous avez des médias
privés euh détenus par des boîtes
privées. Et là, vous avez différents
systèmes. Vous pouvez avoir des sociétés
commerciales, je sais pas le monde,
Libération.
Euh vous pouvez avoir un modèle de
coopérative, ce qui a été le cas depuis
des années à Eltaro qui vient de fêter
ses 40 ans, ce qui est le cas à Nice
Matin. Vous avez un modèle beaucoup plus
rare dans le cas des médias sous la
forme d'association, c'est le cas de
Westfance. Vous avez depuis récemment le
cas de médias comme Média Part qui a
pris le statut de fondation, enfin de
fond de dotation. Syerview, je sais pas,
j'imagine que vous êtes association loi
de 1901.
Non non, on n'est pas association, on
est une société. Vous
êtes société commerciale
vous ? vous, vous refusez les
financements de de l'État. Mais si vous
acceptiez la TVA tout réduit, vous
seriez société commerciale. Du coup,
vous êtes salarié de votre propre
société et en même temps, vous pouvez
potentiellement toucher des aides
publiques. Moi, je veux pas des
journalistes fonctionnaires. C'est pas
pareil de dire qu'il faut de l'argent
public pour financer de l'information
qui coûte cher à produire et qui n'est
plus financé aujourd'hui par la
publicité. et ce qui est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose. C'est pas pareil de
dire qu'il faut de l'argent public pour
financer ça que de dire qu'il faut des
journalistes fonctionnaires. Il faut des
journalistes salariés indépendants qu'on
laisse faire leur travail dans les
meilleures conditions.
Croissance ou décroissance ?
Bah ça dépend comment on la mesure. Il y
a un problème aujourd'hui avec les
indicateurs. Si c'est juste croissance
du PIB, ça marche pas. On sait très bien
que ça marche pas. Bah tout à l'heure,
on parlait des ressources naturelles, de
la relance par la consommation
d'énergie. Je veux dire, si juste
mesurer la croissance par le fait que
vous allez tripler la consommation de
pétrole, bah ça peut pas marcher pour le
futur. Maintenant, je vais vous prendre
un autre cas qui m'a vachement marqué
parce que je suis prof. Euh comment on
mesure le PIB et donc en partie de la
croissance pour tout ce qui est la
fonction publique justement et notamment
l'enseignement, ce qui est quand même
une énorme partie de la fonction
publique à partir des salaires. Je peux
vous assurer que depuis le début du
premier confinement, les conditions
d'enseignement sont super dégradées,
hein. Euh c'est le cas à l'école
primaire, c'est le cas au collège, c'est
le cas au lycée, c'est le cas à
l'université. Ça veut pas dire que les
profs ont pas leur boulot. On fait de on
fait de son mieux pour faire notre
boulot. Moi, j'enseigne en ami euh sur
mon ordi qui fait à peu près la taille
du vôtre. Vous avez 350 étudiants. Vous
vous êtes en tout petit devant la
caméra. Je sais pas ce que j'en apprends
à mes étudiants. Sérieux, je fais le
mieux possible. Je sais pas ce que j'en
rappends beaucoup moins que l'an dernier
ou que l'année d'avant. Bah au niveau du
PIB, le fait que vous ayez confiné tout
l'enseignement,
ça a pas bougé le PIB parce que mon
salaire c'est le même. Et donc on voit
bien qu'en fait toutes les mesures qu'on
a actuelles pour mesurer la croissance,
elles fonctionnent pas et du coup il
faut développer des nouveaux
indicateurs. Par contre sur ce débat
croissance des croissances, je pense que
la vraie question à poser, c'est la
question de l'emploi. Quel emploi ? Quel
emploi on veut ? Comment on fait pour
donner à des gens des emplois qui leur
permettent d'avoir une rémunération
décente et des emplois qui soient aussi
des emplois décents où il y a un
épanouissement au travail ? Et ça, je
pense qu'il y a énormément de choses
qu'on pourrait améliorer et que si
justement on sort de ces indicateurs
purement bêtement économiques, taux de
croissance, pas taux de croissance,
progression du PIB, et ben on aura déjà
fait un grand pas en avant.
Le fait qu'on ajoute au PIB
le commerce de la drogue et de la
prostitution, c'est
je vois que ça vous fait sourire,
non ? Ben alors, mais sur la sur la
question de de de la prostitution, du
commerce de la de la drogue, c'est c'est
ça fait partie des activités économiques
d'une certaine manière. Comment on
mesure le PIB ? Le PIB c'est le produit
intérieur brut, c'est la production
intérieur brute. Donc c'est mesuré par
les échanges et par les flux commerciaux
et financiers. Donc à partir du moment
où oui, vous allez voir un ou une
prostituée et que vous payez une
prestation sexuelle tarifée, vous avez
un échange financier. Cet argent là par
le la prostituée va être utilisé pour
acheter d'autres biens ou d'autres
services. Donc c'est pas anormal que ça
rentre dans le PIB. Après on peut
s'interroger, est-ce qu'on veut que ça
soit légal, illégal ? Est-ce qu'on veut
l'interdire, pas l'interdire ? Comment
on fait pour mieux protéger les
prostituées ? Tout ça, il faut
s'interroger là-dessus. Franchement, se
poser la question, est-ce que c'est dans
le PIB ou pas ? Sérieusement, on s'en
fout. Non,
ça permet de redresser le PIB, un coup
de cric.
Bah, pas que le PIB.
Pardon.
Revenons à nos moutons. Quand on voit
euh les marchés financiers exploser
parce que on va pas commencer à souffrir
le le quand on voit les les marchés
financiers tablés et augmenté pleine
balle en disant oui mais c'est parce que
on fait confiance à la numérisation de
l'économie, le Covid blab bla bla bla
aider l'économie à se numériser. C'est
vachement bien. Hop les indices
boursiers au cric avec de l'argent
magique. Mais c'est pas que pour ça que
ça explose, hein. Il y a différentes
raisons pour lesquelles ça explose et ça
explose plus ou moins que pour enfin des
mauvaises raisons. Euh regardez ce que
font les banques centrale pour relancer
l'économie. Ce qui est pas mauvais en
soi d'ailleurs, elles impriment donc
elles mettent de l'argent dans
l'économie
qui se concentre.
Sauf que cet argent qui est mis dans
l'économie, il va se concentrer et bien
sur la bourse, sur les activités
financières et sur le fait d'acheter
énormément de titres. Donc vous avez eu
en fait pendant des années après la
première crise financière une explosion
de marché immobilier parce que vous
aviez beaucoup injecté euh d'argent dans
l'économie et que les gens font quoi ?
Ils épargnent cet argent. Donc comme il
l'épargne, ensuite c'est les banques qui
vont l'investir euh qui vont l'investir
en bourse, qui vont l'investir sur les
marchés financiers et ça rentre pas dans
l'économie réelle. C'est ça vraiment le
problème en fait. Pourquoi cette relance
actuelle conduit à une explosion des
valeurs boursières et pas une
augmentation des salaires ? Parce qu'on
investit pas dans l'économie réelle. Et
c'est ça qui est en train de se jouer.
Les gens disent "Mais regardez, on
injecte énormément d'argent, énormément
de liquidité. Tous les modèles
économiques, quand on a une telle
injonction de liquidité devrai vous dire
il y a de l'inflation, il devrait y
avoir de l'inflation et ça serait pas
une mauvaise chose d'ailleurs qu'il y a
un peu d'inflation.
Vous Bah alors, bah c'est vraiment pas
là où on est du tout. La stackflation
c'est l'époque Giscar. Donc là, on est
vraiment à l'inverse. La stackflation,
c'était pour le coup dans les années 70
quand on injectait beaucoup d'argent
dans l'économie. On injectait de
l'argent dans l'économie pour sortir de
la stagnation euh économique pour
essayer de de créer de la croissance, de
créer de l'emploi, on n'arrivait pas à
le faire et on créait que de
l'inflation. Euh ce qui fait qu'en fait
les gens non seulement il y avait pas
euh d'emploi, mais ils perdaient en
salaire parce qu'il perdaient en salaire
réel. Aujourd'hui, on est dans une
situation encore plus étrange où on a de
la stagnation,
on injecte beaucoup d'argent dans
l'économie mais on a quand même pas
d'inflation. Pourquoi ? Parce que cet
argent-là est pas investi dans
l'économie réelle. Et c'est pour ça
qu'on les retrouve dans les marchés
financiers. Euhù vous avez des bulles
qui sont en train de se former qui vont
finir par exploser. Mais ça c'est
d'abord lié à la politique de relance
euh de la part de la banque centrale.
Ensuite la deuxième question qui se
pose, c'est sur l'économie numérique. Ce
n'est pas normal d'avoir des entreprises
qui sont introduites en bourse à des
valeurs boursières qui ne font
absolument aucun sens alors que ça
correspond pas du tout à leur production
réelle de richesse. Et là faut
s'interroger. Mais ça interroge sur quoi
? Sur le niveau d'inégalité. Ça
interroge sur le fait que vous avez des
gens qui ont plusieurs centaines de
milliers euh d'euros, plusieurs millions
d'euros finalement à investir et comme
en fait ils vont pas l'investir dans
l'économie réelle, bah ils sont prêts à
faire le pari que en mettant de l'argent
sur telle ou telle boîte qui a
absolument rien créé aujourd'hui qui
créera sans doute rien demain, qui est
simplement une innovation technologique,
euh ils vont pouvoir gagner des
dividendes. Et d'ailleurs, ils jouent
que là-dessus, hein. Ils font pas le
pari qu'en investissant dans A plutôt
que dans B, A va faire une véritable
innovation et va leur permettre demain
finalement d'être à la tête d'une
entreprise ou de posséder des actions
d'une entreprise qui auraient gagné de
l'argent. Ils font le pari qu'en
investissant dans A plutôt que dans B,
d'autres gens vont aussi investir dans A
plutôt que dans B. Donc en fait, la
valeur de leurs actions va augmenter et
qui vont faire une plusvalue en sortant.
Et donc vous avez une économie qui est
une économie complètement financiarisée.
On met de l'argent dans cette économie
beaucoup et la plupart des gens voient
pas du tout la couleur de cet argent. Et
c'est pire que ça, c'est non seulement
il voit pas la couleur de cet argent
mais comme vous avez une explosion par
exemple des prix de l'immobilier et ben
ils peuvent pas se loger. Alors ils
peuvent louer un peu. Il peuvent
certainement plus accéder à la propriété
dans les grandes villes sauf s'ils ont
hérité. Donc ils ont même plus accès au
logement parce qu'on a tellement mis de
liquidité dans l'économie qu'on a fait
exploser les prix du tarif. Euh enfin
les les prix sur le marché immobilier,
c'est combien le prix du ticket de métro
?
Euh bah je peux vous dire le prix de mon
paste Navigo qui est de 75 € par mois.
Question internet. Euh
la crise qui vient, on va la gérer
comment ? Par chômage de masse, par
injection de liquidité encore plus, par
On peut continuer à injecter des
liquidités, mais tant qu'on fera pas
rentrer ces liquidités dans l'économie
réelle, ça servira à rien d'injecter des
liquidités. Bah, ça dépend ce qu'on
fait. Euh moi je peux vous dire ce que
je ferai. Euh enfin je vous dis moi je
peux vous dire que je coupe je vous
coupe on injecte des des liquidités
taquet
il faut que ça se retrouve dans
l'économie réelle.
Ouais
donc consommer.
donc produire.
Non mais pas forcément. Regardez un
truc. Regardez un truc qu'on pourrait
faire taper dans le but.
Non non non non. Regardez un truc qu'on
pourrait faire très simplement. Euh
qui sont les enseignants les moins bien
payés d'Europe ?
La France.
Voilà exactement. Comment vous pouvez
injecter des liquidités dans l'économie
réelle ? On augmente le salaire des des
profs.
Ouais. Pas que des profs d'ailleurs.
C'est un peu corporatiste. Non
non. Bah pas à la limite. Moi je suis je
suis en fait salarié à à Sciencep, je
suis en CDD euh et je suis salarié
fonction privée. Donc je suis même pas
je suis même pas fonctionnaire. Je gagne
3500 € par mois ce qui fait que je suis
en fait payé euh en aide et je suis très
très bien payé pour un prof. Pour le
coup, je suis pas fonctionnaire et je
suis même peut-être trop payé pour un
prof. En tout cas, je suis payé à un
niveau supérieur à un mètre de
conférence. Un maître de conférence
aujourd'hui en France, il est payé moins
de 2000 € par mois nette et c'est pas
normal. Un chercheur aussi,
un chercheur au CNRS en France
aujourd'hui, il est payé moins de 2000 €
par mois net et c'est pas normal. Une
infirmière aujourd'hui en France, elle
est payée au demi au début de carrière
moins de 2000 € par mois nette et c'est
pas normal.
Surtout autour de 1300 1500 €.
Ah oui non mais j'étais à 2000 € je vous
ai même pas baissé en dessous mais ils
sont un tout petit peu au-dessus du SMIC
et à peine et encore souvent ils
cumulent des heures sup. Donc ce que je
veux vous dire par là et c'est vraiment
un truc c'est pas corporatif, je suis
pas fonctionnaire et même si j'étais
fonctionnaire, je vous dirai la même
chose. Je m'en fous, faut pas vous
mais non non non, je m'énerve pas. Mais
en fait les les il faut se poser cette
question au bout. Si vous voulez que
l'État utilise ses ressources pour
injecter de l'argent dans l'économie
réelle aujourd'hui, vous payez mieux les
fonctionnaires et vous payez mieux les
fonctionnaires fonctionnaires
territorial. Vous payez mieux les profs,
vous payez mieux les infirmières, vous
payez mieux les médecins à l'hôpital.
Vous augmentez leur salaire.
massivement. Là, vous injectez de
l'argent dans l'économie réelle. Là,
vous consommez rien en plus
immédiatement. Vous permettez déjà à des
gens qui peuvent pas se loger
aujourd'hui de se loger. Vous permettez
à des gens qui bossent comme des fous à
l'hôpital toute la journée de payer des
vacances à leur gosse. Ça c'est la
première chose. La deuxième chose c'est
que il faut penser d'une manière ou
d'une autre des activités qui sont des
activités qui consomment moins en terme
de de de d'activités carbonées mais qui
sont des activités qui peuvent être plus
épanouissantes. Est-ce qu'on a besoin si
on gagne 50 € par en plus à la fin du
mois de s'acheter 5 t-shirts en plus à
10 € ? Pas forcément. Euh par contre,
est-ce qu'avec ces 50 € en plus, ben on
pourrait faire en sorte justement que
euh le cinéma ça soit plus accessible ?
Parce qu'en fait le cinéma, ça coûte
super cher. Euh que les musées euh ça
soit euh plus accessible, que euh les
théâtres ça soient plus accessibles, que
les gens puissent avoir davantage
d'activités par exemple culturelles.
Ouais, on pourrait faire en sorte que ça
soit le cas. Les gens peuvent aussi
acheter euh plus de livres, les gens
peuvent faire plus de sport euh ou aller
davantage voir des compétitions
sportives. Il y a plein de manières
d'être heureux en dépensant de l'argent
sans faire du carbone, sans produire à
tout prix, sans importer à tout prix. Et
c'est ça en fait qu'il faut viser
aujourd'hui. Et sauf que le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout faire
ça qu'on est en train d'attendre.
Question internet. Existe-t-il une
limite à la création monétaire Exnilo ?
Bah la limite à la création monétaire
Exnilo.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exnilo ?
Bah c'est cette idée que les les banques
centrales, elles impriment de la monnaie
euh à partir de rien. Je veux dire le
bilan de la Banque centrale européenne,
il a d'abord doublé, après il a triplé,
après il a quadruplé. Et en fait, on
voit ce bilan de la banque centrale qui
augmente de manière euh infinie. Il y a
pas de plafond d'une certaine manière,
il pourrait continuer à augmenter. Alors
qu'est-ce qui l'empêche d'augmenter plus
? Alors pour l'instant, ben rien, il
continue à augmenter. Il y a un truc qui
fait qu'on arrête la création monétaire,
c'est quand il y a trop d'inflation.
Ouais.
Alors le problème c'est que si on le
fait trop tard et que vous êtes rentré
dans un espèce de cycle
d'hyperinflation, bah en fait vous êtes
emballé, vous pouvez pas en sortir.
Aujourd'hui, il y a pas de risque hein.
Aujourd'hui, on imprime quand on est
malade, il y a pas d'inflation. Par
contre, il y a un risque,
c'est une bulle financière.
Ils ont peur de la déflation.
Bah, ça serait embêtant de rentrer en
déflation. Alors, on n'est pas
exactement dans une situation de
déflation. On est plutôt à 0,5 1 %
d'inflation. Donc, a priori, on devrait
pas tomber en déflation. C'est pas
vraiment le risque qui menace. Mais
vraiment, le risque qui menace
aujourd'hui, c'est l'explosion d'une
bulle financière. On a mis trop de
liquidité dans l'économie financière. On
n' pas assez mis de liquidité dans
l'économie réelle. Et puis l'autre
problème par rapport à ça, par rapport à
cette vision exnilo, quand vous voyez le
bilan de la banque centrale qui est
double, qui triple, qui est quadruple,
dès que vous avez des banques en
difficulté, euh dès que vous avez des
états euh en difficulté, après les gens
qui eux disent euh mais attendez, on
aimerait bien euh qu'on nous gratte pas
5 € pour les APL ou les gens qui ont des
petites retraites qui aimeraient bien
qu'on leur gratte pas 100 € sur leur
retraite en leur faisant augmenter la
CSG et qu'on leur dit on n pas les
moyens. L'État vit au-dessus de ses
moyens là. Je sais pas ce qu'ils sont en
train de nous faire. J'ai vu, ils
mettent en place une nouvelle commission
spéciale sur la dette. Mettre en place
une commission spéciale sur la dette.
Mais les gens, je veux dire, c'est c'est
la rationalité des gens. Les citoyens,
ils ont raison de s'interroger, de se
dire "Mais attendez, pourquoi on a
triplé le bilan de la Banque centrale
européenne ?" Et là, quand il s'agit de
mon salaire, mais pas de multiplier mon
salaire par 3 hein, simplement de de me
remettre 100 € à la fin du mois parce
que je m'en sors plus, on va dire qu'on
a plus les moyens. Et c'est ça aussi,
c'est cette espèce de d'immense
incompréhension. Et on prend pas le
temps euh d'expliquer aux gens comment
ça marche la banque centrale.
Compréhension ou c'est du foutage de
gueule ? Est-ce qu'on complexifie ?
Ah ouais, bien cette image de Macron
construit comme président ultra
intelligent, le plus intelligent de tous
les présidents. Euh le président des
riches qui comprendrait mieux que tout
le monde parce qu'il a fait l'inspection
générale des finances. Et par contre les
citoyens, nous on serait pas capable de
comprendre. Moi, ça fait partie des
trucs que j'essaie de faire comme prof
un peu. Euh mais surtout la la raison
pour laquelle j'ai choisi d'écrire des
bouquins et des bouquins de
vulgarisation euh mais vulgarisation
sauce positive du terme, c'est que je
pense qu'il y a pas de sujet technique,
il y a pas de sujet que les gens
puissent pas comprendre. Il faut leur
prendre le temps euh de de les amener au
fond des choses justement pour les
éclairer et éclairer leur décision
et après c'est à eux de faire les choix.
Question très intéressante. Faut-il
repenser la propriété privée ?
Ouais, il faut repenser la propriété
privée. En fait, il faut repenser la
progressivité de la taxation. Repenser
la progressivité de la taxation, ça
revient à repenser la propriété privée.
Quand on parle d'impôt sur la fortune,
ça veut dire quoi l'impôt sur la fortune
? Quand vous avez un impôt, quand vous
en avez pas, bah ça c'est facile. Votre
propriété privée, vous pouvez la la
conserver advitam eternum et comme en
général plus elle est importante, plus
ça s'accumule. Donc par exemple, plus
vous avez de capital en banque, plus
vous allez avoir de taux d'intérêt, vous
allez avoir finalement une accumulation
de la propriété privée au cours du
temps. Comment vous faites finalement
pour mettre fin à ça ? Bah vous faites
de l'impôt sur la propriété privée,
l'impôt sur le capital, l'impôt sur la
fortune, le taux d'imposition sur la
fortune. Si vous avez des taux marginaux
à 2 %, bon bah sachant que le retour sur
investissement va être supérieur à 2 %,
vous pouvez permettre l'accumulation de
la propriété privée. Si maintenant on
dit bah moi je ne pense pas que dans une
démocratie comme la France, quelqu'un
ait le droit de posséder plus de 500
millions d'euros de capital. Et je vous
dis volontairement un truc très très
gros hein parce qu'on pourrait dire plus
de 100 millions hein ou plus de 50
millions mais même plus de 500 et ben du
coup à 500 millions d'euros ben je mets
un taux marginal d'imposition sur la
fortune à 50 %.
Et ben je veux dire en 2 ans
c'est confiscatoire.
Non c'est pas confiscatoire c'est la
redistribution mais il faut bien qu'il y
ait une limite à l'accumulation de
richesse. Là vous avez des gens
aujourd'hui qui ont des patrimoines de
l'ordre de 3 4 5 6 7 10 milliards
d'euros.
Après, il faut qu'on ait cette
discussion collectivement. C'est ça la
démocratie. cette discussion
la démocratie c'est décider
collectivement quel est le meilleur taux
d'imposition marginale du capital et du
travail.
Ces discussions collectives, on va la
voir avec des fourche
à l'ancienne. Est-ce qu'on va reprendre
les traditions françaises pour avoir des
discussions collectives ?
Bah le problème c'est qu'avec une
fourche on discute pas et que parfois on
fait des conneries au passage.
Voilà et du coup moi je préfère discuter
avec les jaunes que discuter avec les
fourches. Et c'est pour ça que j'en
reviens. Je suis désolé he c'est pas un
dada. Mais si on avait une gauche un peu
moins con qui allait uni
candidat de gauche pour l'élection en
2022 qui mène une politique de gauche
une fois élue, c'estàdire réintroduction
de l'ISF, pas avec les taux qu'on avait
avantigé
obligé de de rajouter qui mène une
politique de gauche une fois élue. Bah
parce que la dernière fois qu'on a eu un
président socialiste, il a pas vraiment
mené une politique de gauche.
D'ailleurs, il faut pas se voiler la
face. Enfin, moi j'ai toujours été à
gauche et historiquement, j'ai toujours
voté socialiste. Et maintenant, si je
fais le bilan, qu'est-ce que je vois ?
Il faut pas simplement se dire le
problème du quinquena Hollande depuis
81, entre 80 et aujourd'hui, cours des
40 dernières années.
Bah bah si vous voulez déjà, il y a
plein de fois, j'ai voté socialiste,
c'est la droite qui a gagné.
Comme ça, voilà. Euh, est-ce que je me
sens Ouais. Est-ce que je me dis que
j'ai fait une connerie en 2012 ? Bah, si
vous regardez le quinquena 2012-27, d'un
point de vue économique, c'est pas un
quinquena qui a fait beaucoup de progrès
sociaux. Enfin, au contraire, c'est
plutôt un quinquena qui a marqué
justement le village le virage libéral
du Parti socialiste et qui a fait naître
Macron avec tout ce qui est CICE. Alors,
heureusement, il y a des trucs bien qui
ont été fait. On peut nommer le mariage
pour tous et heureusement qu'il y a eu
Tobira. Heureusement qu'il y a eu le
mariage pour tous mais 20127,
ça a un peu 5 années de perdu en terme
de de justice sociale et de
redistribution économique. Et c'est vrai
que si je prends du recul pas que sur le
quinquena Hollande, que je regarde de 81
à aujourd'hui, c'est la gauche qui a été
majoritairement au pouvoir dans ce pays.
Voilà. et les inégalités, elles ont
augmenté. Aujourd'hui, on a plus d'impôt
sur la fortune. Vous avez un salaire
minimum qui reste à un niveau
extrêmement faible, vous avez pas
justement de revenus universels, vous
avez pas suffisamment de redistribution.
Je pense que la gauche a pas exactement
bien fait tout son boulot. Je veux pas
donner de leçons, je veux dire, avant
j'étais jeune, j'ai jamais été au
pouvoir, j'ai jamais vraiment fait de
politique. Donc, il s'agit pas de de
prendre des gens et les clouer à un mur
et de dire mauvais mauvais mauvais. Euh
vous êtes des erreurs de l'histoire, il
s'agit pas du tout de faire ça. Par
contre, il s'agit de tirer des leçons en
terme de politique et de se dire que si
demain la gauche elle est au pouvoir,
c'est pas pour mener une politique de
droite et qu'il va falloir avoir les les
moyens de ses ambitions et que ces
ambitions, ça doivent être des ambitions
qui visent à davantage de
redistribution, davantage de
progressivité de l'impôt et on peut
l'appeler si vous voulez le fait de
repenser la propriété privée.
La croissance verte, c'est du bullshit.
Ça dépend ce qu'on met derrière. Moi
j'aime pas ces expressions qui sont
toutes faites. Euh si vous dites la la
full sinking, du window dressing, de de
quoi ? De l'enfumage, du sculptage d'air
chaud, du brassage de fumée.
Bah il faut lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique. C'est ça la
vérité.
Ça on a tous compris ça
non ? Bah la plupart des gens ont pas
compris dans les politiques qui mettent
en œuvre. Ils ont pas compris. Enfin, je
veux dire là fait je crois c'est quoi
les 5 ans de l'accord de Paris. La
France, elle respecte pas du tout les
engagements qu'elle a pris. Les gens ont
pas compris. Je sais pas s'il faut
parler de croissance verte. Ce qui ce
dont il faut parler, c'est de la
réduction des émissions de CO2 et pour
l'instant on tient pas nos engagements.
Donc il faut faire en sorte de tenir nos
engagements en terme de réduction des
émissions de CO2. Vous avez plein de
gens qui vous parlent de croissance
verte et en même temps on taxe toujours
pas le kérosène sur les avions.
Bon, ils ont pas compris. Donc moi, je
pense à la fois qu'il faut de l'emploi,
il faut de la protection sociale. Parler
du revenu universel, il faut augmenter
les salaires, notamment des gens qui
sont pas assez bien payés. Et si on
augmente les salaires justement des gens
qui sont dans la santé, dans le secteur
de l'éducation, vous augmentez les
salaires de de professions qui sont des
professions enrichissantes sans
augmenter la pollution, est-ce qu'on
nous dit croissance verte ? Croissance
verte en général, c'est c'est pour les
gens qui disent "Oui oui oui oui oui,
j'ai bien conscience de l'environnement
mais quand même on va faire de la
croissance." J'aime pas les formules
toutes faites. C'est pour ça que j'aime
pas non plus 6e République. Je pense
qu'il faut changer d'institution pour de
vrai hein. On parlait tout à l'heure du
vote obligatoire. Je pense qu'il faut
revenir aussi sur le système
présidentiel. Je pense qu'il faut
complètement interdire les dons aux
partis politiques au-delà de 200 €. Je
pense qu'il faut refinancer entièrement
la structure de euh de de financement
des médias. Je pense qu'il y a des
énormes changements institutionnel à
faire. Je pense qu'il faut introduire le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne. Mais
parlons de ça. Parlons des trucs
précisément plutôt que dire 6e
République. Après, on appellera ça 6e,
7e, c'est pas grave. Mais on parle pas
des détails des choses. Et c'est
important de rentrer dans les détails
des choses. Dire croissance he c'est
prendre les gens pour des cons en fait.
Question internet, elle en pense quoi
des cryptos ?
Crypto quoi ? Cryptocurrency. Ouais,
cryptomonnaie,
Bitcoin quoi.
Oui. Oui. Ou plein d'autres.
Je je c'est je trouve que la question de
la blockchain est une question qui est
vachement intéressante. Je pense que le
le fait de sécuriser des transactions,
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
intéressant. Il y a pas mal de projets,
il y en a qui se sont qui ont pas
marché. Euh mais j'avais suivi euh
d'assez près tout ce qui avait été fait
par euh consensie au au aux États-Unis
autour de l'idée d'avoir de du
journalisme protégé par de la blockchain
justement pour éviter d'avoir un
actionnaire derrière qui repasse et qui
réécrive un un article. Donc toutes ces
technologies-là sont des technologies
intéressantes. Ensuite, si vous regardez
les Bitcoin en soi, malheureusement, on
pourrait voir ça comme une belle
innovation qui permet de sortir
justement simplement de la logique des
États et de la logique des bandes
centrales. En vérité, le Bitcoin, ça a
été quoi ? Ça a été une manière surtout
euh bah pour des gens de spéculer en
bourse. Alors ils appellent pas ça la
bourse, ils appellent les Bitcoin. Mais
bon, la plupart des gens que j'ai vu
jouer avec des Bitcoin, ils ont gagné de
l'argent avec. Ils ont été contents. Ils
ont gagné de l'argent avec le Bitcoin.
Ils ont fait des paris sur le marché du
Bitcoin. Ils sont ressortis du Bitcoin,
ils sont rentrés dans le Bitcoin. Je
pense pas que ça va révolutionner le
monde. Et en plus, ça consomme vachement
d'énergie.
Question internet. Que répond-t-elle
quand on lui dit que le revenu universel
ne va créer que de l'inflation ? Bah ça
c'est pas vrai. Euh déjà encore une fois
si on créait un peu d'inflation, ça
serait pas mal. Première chose. 2è chose
et ça ça c'est pour le coup alors on va
revenir à cette question du revenu
universel et la version que je défends.
Moi je pense que le revenu universel, il
faut le donner aux gens qui en ont
besoin. Si vous faites un chèque à 60
millions de français de 500 € et vous
injectez comme ça 500 € à 60 millions de
français, bah potentiellement vous allez
juste augmenter les prix. Là, l'idée
c'est d'aller aider les gens qui n'ont
rien, qui n'ont pas assez, qui ont à
peine le RSA et qui ont pas assez pour
vivre avec le RSA ou qui ont pas le RSA
parce qu'ils perdent le RSA ou qu'ils
ont pas fait toutes les démarches euh
pour demander le RSA. Euh franchement,
si on créait 1 ou 2 % d'inflation pour
sortir 100 millions de français de la
précarité en leur donnant simplement une
sécurité économique qui leur permette de
vivre dans des conditions décentes, bah
sérieux, on crée 2 % d'inflation, c'est
pas très grave et ça nous ferait pas de
mal d'avoir un tout petit peu
d'inflation, surtout si on en revient à
la question précédente qui était la
question de la dette, parce que quand
même une des meilleures manières
d'effacer discrètement la dette quand
elle s'est trop accumulée, c'est en
faisant un peu d'inflation. C'est ça qui
paye.
Bah alors dans ce cas-là euh les gens
qui ont de l'épargne, si vous effacez la
dette en faisant de l'inflation, vous
faites payer les gens qui ont de
l'épargne. C'est pour ça que je pense
pas que l'inflation, ça soit la
meilleure manière d'effacer la dette. Je
pense qu'il faut mieux effacer la dette
en taxant les plus riches, en utilisant
l'impôt des plus riches pour rembourser
une partie de la dette. Le problème de
juste le faire par l'inflation, c'est
que vous avez plein de petits
épargnants, des gens qui vont avoir
50000 100000 € à la banque, des gens qui
vont avoir leur mis de l'argent de côté
pour leur retraite et vous allez aussi
leur grignoter. Euh donc c'est une
manière d'effacer la dette qui est
plutôt assez inégale parce qu'elle va
toucher tout le monde de la même
manière. Quand vous le faites par
l'impôt progressif, bah ça permet de le
faire de manière aussi redistributive
avec davantage de justice fiscale.
Question internet. Euh est-ce qu'elle
peut nous donner son avis sur un papier
de l'OPS d'aujourd'hui ? L'économiste
Cohen a reçu de Veolia une sommation
interpellative à son domicile
parce qu'il avait critiqué la fusion
Volia Su.
Alors, j'ai pas eu le temps de lire
l'article mais mais j'ai vu passer la
brève. Alors, ça m'a fait un peu rigoler
parce que comment dire, I Cohen c'est
pas vraiment un révolutionnaire et c'est
plutôt un économiste qui est vraiment
dans le système et qui va plutôt
d'habitude d'être du côté des
entreprises, bah du côté du pouvoir, du
côté du gouvernement qui a qui a très
fortement porté les couleurs d'Emmanuel
Macron. pendant longtemps. Et donc c'est
vrai que d'habitude on s'attend pas
vraiment à ce qu'il se fasse taper
dessus y compris par une boîte quoi.
Donc le fait de voir qu'il ait cette
sommation parce qu'il aurait critiquer
la la fusion entre Véolias, ça m'a fait
quand même un peu sourire. Ensuite sur
le fond du truc, c'est pas parce que
c'esten qu'il faut faire du délit de
sale gueule. C'est extrêmement embêtant
que ça soit pour des journalistes ou
pour des chercheurs. Qu'une boîte puisse
attaquer en justice un chercheur comme
un journaliste parce que celui-là
celui-cif dernier parce que le chercheur
donne son opinion. ou donne son opinion
de citoyen ou donne son opinion éclairée
euh de chercheurs. Je trouve ça
extrêmement problématique. Euh ça
devrait pas être le cas en en en
démocratie. On parlait tout à l'heure de
de la question des des procédures
billons
toujours. On est en démocratie.
Question d'internet.
Bah j'ai mon mon dernier bouquin euh qui
s'appelle libre et ég voi. La première
phrase c'est la démocratie existe pas.
La deuxième c'est elle reste elle reste
à inventer parce que je pense qu'on peut
toujours faire mieux. On est davantage
en démocratie en France qu'en Russie. On
est davantage en démocratie en France
qu'en Turquie. On est davantage en
démocratie en France qu'aux États-Unis.
Est-ce que notre système démocratique
aujourd'hui fonctionne bien ? Non.
Est-ce qu'il est urgent de le repenser ?
Oui. Est-ce qu'il faut refondre nos
institutions également ?
Est-ce qu'on a quand même un peu de
liberté ?
Encore heureux. On peut encore aller
manifester. Par contre, ça devient
chiant de se prendre des gaz à la fin de
chaque manifestation.
Oui. Ou des LBD 40 en pleine tête.
Ça, j'en ai pas pris encore. Des gaz.
Ouais.
Ça, on pourra revenir. On va en parler
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs du LBD40. On a
deux amis policiers qui viennent de
rejoindre mais on a encore du temps
ensemble. Et question d'internet, le
Brexit a été conforté par l'élection de
Johnson. Qu'en pense-t-elle ?
Bah en fait le le le
Brexit, c'est vraiment le pire coup
politique euh de l'histoire de toute la
politique, quoi. Euh c'est c'est le
digne euh mise en forme britannique de
ce qu'avait fait Chirac avec euh la
dissolution en 97. En fait, c'est quand
même beaucoup plus grave. Euh mais pour
pour être tout à fait sérieux, le le
Brexit, il avait été proposé par les
conservateurs britanniques, sachant
qu'ils en voulaient pas. Donc c'était
une espèce de manière de faire un coup
politique en se disant bon, on va faire
un référendum sur le Brexit comme ça on
va le gagner et comme on aura gagné le
référendum euh on en sortira renforcé
politiquement et ça permettra de faire
terre les critiques du Labor. Euh à
l'arrivée, vous avez ça mais les
conservateurs disent quand même bah il
faut surtout pas le Brexit. Le Labor dit
il faut pas le Brexit mais quand même
vous avez Corbin qui fait pas une
campagne extrêmement forte pour rester
dans l'Union européenne parce qu'il y a
quand même pas mal de dysfonctionnement
aussi avec l'Union européenne. Donc
finalement les parties se font prendre à
leur complètement propre jeu et paf les
gens votent pour le Brexit. Derrière,
vous avez Boris Johnson qui arrive, qui
est un conservateur
à tendance, alors j'aime pas ce mot
populiste, mais à un conservateur
extrêmement libéral, euh extrêmement euh
Ouais. Enfin, tourner vers les
entreprises, tourner vers le libéralisme
économique. Euh qui finalement voit
aussi dans le dans le Brexit un certain
nombre d'avantages pour l'économie
britannique dont on pourrait vouloir
faire alors d'ailleurs, c'est un Paris
que je pense ils vont perdre. euh avec
la City à Londres, un espèce de nouveau
paradis financier. Et donc lui, il
rentre aussi complètement dans ce jeu
euh politiquement et il se dit bah il
refait d'ailleurs des votes autour du
Brexit. Vous avez tout vous avez quand
même eu un un invisemblable succession
de premier ministre, d'imbrogliot, de
vote à la chambre, de défiance, de
confiance dans un sens et dans l'autre.
Enfin, qui montre d'ailleurs qu'on s'en
sort pas du tout. À l'arrivée, est-ce
que ce qui est intéressant, c'est
d'analyser les tenants et les
aboutissants de la politique britannique
? Pas tellement. Moi ce que je je je
vois plutôt là-dedans, c'est que c'est
vraiment une manière pour le coup de
jouer avec les citoyens britanniques,
d'en faire des espèces de de de pion
finalement. Alors que le Brexit, pour le
coup, ça va avoir des conséquences
concrètes euh qui sont des conséquences
concrètes extrêmement fortes euh y
compris pour les citoyens britanniques
et potentiellement aussi d'ailleurs pour
le reste de de l'Union européenne. Et ça
fait 2 ans qu'on les trimbale là dedans
comme dans un espèce de grand pot qu'on
aurait appelé Brexit qu'on secoue dans
tous les sens et on sait pas trop bien
ce qui va en sortir. Simplement que
certains s'accrochent à ça pour rester
au pouvoir.
Une question de ma petite Kaaille, que
penses-t-elle du grand Resette ?
Je sais pas ce que c'est. Alors, il y a
Christine Lagarde qui nous dit "Voilà,
on va faire un grand reset de l'économie
mondiale."
Ah, vous dites reset reset. Ah oui, on
dit reset comme quand on met
comme quand quand on met à zéro un
ordinateur. Euh, c'est ça. Ouais.
Un gros coup de pompe.
Bah, en général, j'ai pas une confiance
monumentale dans Christine Lagarde.
Donc, je sais pas exactement.
Christine Lagarde, on pourrait faire son
bilan euh comme ministre en France.
C'était déjà pas une grande réussite. Il
faut quand même pas oublier que c'était
elle qui était derrière tous les
arbitrages qui ont été faits au moment
de de la faire Bernard Tapi. Je veux
dire, on l'a quand même un peu oublié au
passage. Après,
elle est pas coupable.
Non, elle est pas elle est pas elle est
pas coupable. Elle a pas été reconnue
coupable. Donc, elle est innocente, mais
elle a quand même signé tous les
documents. Euh, en tout cas, elle était
présente euh dans la big picture. Euh si
si on doit faire des anglicismes. Euh
ensuite au FMI, B. Moi je sais pas c'est
quoi son bilan à Christine Lagarde. Il
m'a pas l'air particulièrement positif.
Il y a quoi ? Il y a quelle grande
mesure, quelle grande trace
Christine Lagarde a laissé de son
passage au FMI.
Bah il y a la tro en Grèce. Allez
demander aux Grecs s'ils ont un bon
souvenir de Christine Lagarde. J'en suis
pas tout à fait sûr. Donc au FMI a
priori elle a quand même pas fait un
super bon boulot. Alors on peut dire que
la garde est pas non plus coupable de ce
qui s'est passé en Grèce. elle était
quand même en partie en charge. Euh donc
aujourd'hui,
si je dois prendre la Banque centrale
européenne, elle a joué le jeu dans son
ensemble, elle a injecté des liquidités,
elle l'a fait parce qu'elle en était
obligée, qu'elle l'a fait parce que
c'était la garde, est-ce qu'elle
l'aurait fait sans la garde ? Je pense
qu'elle l'aurait fait dans un cas comme
dans l'autre. Ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui remettre toutes les
économies à zéro ? Est-ce que si on
devait repenser fondamentalement le
fonctionnement de nos économies, il
faudrait le faire ? Oui, faut repenser
la propriété, on les disait tout à
l'heure, il faut repenser les échanges
internationaux. Là, on a mis tous les
avions au sol, par exemple. Tout le
monde aurait dit que c'était
complètement impossible de remettre tous
les avions au sol. On a remis tous les
avions au sol. Bah, ça serait peut-être
le moment de s'interroger sur notre
pratique du voyage en avion. Est-ce
qu'on va le faire ? Ce que je veux dire,
c'est que est-ce qu'il faudrait prendre
le temps de la crise sanitaire pour tout
remettre à zéro ? Ouais.
Est-ce que c'est Christine Lagarde qui
va le faire ? Non. Est-ce que c'est
Emmanuel Macron ? Non plus.
Donc il faut quand même attendre de
l'alternance politique. Bah il se trouve
qu'en France, il y a une bonne nouvelle,
il y a une élection dans un an et demi.
C'est un peu tard d'ailleurs. J'espère
qu'il va y avoir des changements avant.
Mais au moins espérons qu'on ait une
vraie alternance dans un an et demi.
Si si on se tape une explosion
financière, vous conseillez de stocker
vos axifs dans quoi ? Dans l'or, dans
les cryptos ? sans sans tomber sur le le
conseil financier bien entendu. Mais
vous vous stockiez vos
vos vos actifs dans quoi ?
Alors moi j'ai pas j'ai pas beaucoup
d'actifs euh mais si je choisissais de
stocker mes actifs et si je m'écoutais
spontanément euh je déciderais de
devenir propriétaire. Euh il se trouve
que je suis en couple avec quelqu'un qui
aime pas beaucoup la propriété. Donc
même la propriété immobilière, on n pas
franchi de pas. On est juste locataire
et on n'est pas des grands stockers
d'actifs. Euh, j'aime bien l'idée de
propriété mobile de redistribution des
des actifs. Euh je pense qu'il faut de
la redistribution fondamentalement. Je
pense aujourd'hui pour quelqu'un par
contre qui a pas beaucoup d'actifs euh
quand on a la menace d'une crise
financière, le meilleur placement c'est
l'immobilier. Sauf qu'en fait
aujourd'hui c'est pas forcément le
meilleur moment pour s'endetter si on
pense qu'il a la menace d'une crise
immobilière d'une crise financière.
Mais ça ça c'est pas ce que disent les
les banquiers qu'on connaît là.
Mais c'est qui les banquers ? Moi je
connais pas de banquiers.
les banquiers qu'on connaît, ils nous
disent surtout pas l'immobilier parce
que c'est pas liquide et que si on se
tape un un gros coup de grisou, la
première chose que l'État va taxer,
c'est les biens pas liquides et ça se
transporte pas.
Mais oui, mais ça mais d'accord, mais
alors là, vous parlez à qui ? Moi, je
pensais qu'on parlait au on parlait de
vous, de moi et des gens qui nous
regardaient. Euh ouais, je pense que si
aujourd'hui vous êtes multimillionnaire
ou multimilliardaire, de toute façon,
vous investissez pas dans l'immobilier.
Euh vous investissez dans les paradis
fiscaux, vous investissez dans les
actifs financiers. Euh c'est des actifs
ultra mobiles qui vous permettent de
bouger euh d'un d'un côté à l'autre et
d'échapper à l'impôt. D'ailleurs, vous
noterez que Macron, il a pas supprimé
l'ISF, il a transformé l'ISF en nifi.
Impôt sur la fortune immobilière. Ils se
sont dit vraiment les seuls qu'on peut
pas taxer, c'est les mecs qui sont pas
mobiles. Donc eux, on va les taxer.
Maintenant là, je parlais de gens qui
selon moi étaient à peu près au
patrimoine médian, 150000 200000 allez
peut-être 300 400000 d'actifs mais pas
plus. à 300 400000 d'actifs quand je
vous dis vous investissez dans la
propriété immobilière, ça veut dire quoi
? Vous mettez un toit sur la tête quoi.
Vous achetez votre logement, vous
achetez votre logement et votre logement
si vous avez un logement qui vaut 400000
€ si demain il y a des taxes, on va pas
taxer un logement qui vaut 400000 €.
Quoique il faut dire que aujourd'hui on
a un système de taxation en France, on
n' pas d'impôts sur la fortune parce
qu'il faut pas taxer les patrimoines.
Sauf qu'on a une taxe foncière euh qui
est extrêmement important et que en fait
du coup euh on taxe les gens qui ont des
logements qui valent 150000 € même s'ils
ont 120000 € de dette et 30000 € de
revenu de patrimoine net. Et ça aussi,
il faudrait revoir cette manière de de
taxer euh le patrimoine et pas taxer la
valeur euh de de l'immobilier que vous
avez, mais taxer au niveau du patrimoine
net des individus. Parce que quelqu'un
qui a un un un immeuble, un logement,
une maison à 500000 € et 400000 € de
dette et qui va payer le même impôt que
quelqu'un qui a 500000 € en immobilier
plus 5 millions d'euros en actif
financier, mais là-dessus, il y a plus
d'impôt sur la fortune, n'occupez plus
rien. Bah, c'est pas une société qui est
très juste.
Question internet de The King. E Julia,
tu en penses quoi de science Po ?
Ah, The King, je pensais que vous vous
allez me parler de Cantona. Euh
bonjour d'ailleurs,
c'est mon employeur
donc je suis contente d'y enseigner. Euh
vous êtes contente parce que c'est votre
employeur ?
Non. Bah pour être tout à fait honnête
tout à l'heure vous me demandiez mon
salaire. Je gagne plus en étant un
science pour qu'en étant maître de
conférence et c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
assez payé en France quand on est maître
de conférence. Je vais pas faire pleurer
dans les chaumières, je gagne très bien
ma vie. Quand je suis rentré des
États-Unis, j'ai refusé des salaires qui
étaient quatre fois supérieurs parce
qu'on paye beaucoup trop les les euh les
chercheurs dans les grandes facéres.
Donc, j'ai été content d'avoir un point
de chute euh qui me permet de gagner un
peu mieux ma vie et notamment de pouvoir
louer un un appart à Paris que si
j'avais été maître de conférence. Il y a
ça, il y a des conditions de travail qui
sont extrêmement bonnes. On enseigne pas
énormément à Sciencep. Voilà, je vous
dis tout, vous saurez tout sur Science
Po à Science Po on enseigne 72 heures
par an à la facon enseigne 200 heures
par an. Donc ça me permet de faire
beaucoup plus de de recherche et on a
des bonnes conditions de travail là où
malheureusement à l'université, mais ce
qu'il faudrait c'est revoir
l'université, euh vous laissez euh les
gens s'empiler dans les amphilles, les
amphiilles s'écroulent et quand je vais
filer euh des cours à Saint-en ou à
Nterre ou même à Parisen qui fait quand
même partie des des fac les mieux
dotées, parfois vous devez, je rigole
pas arriver avec votre rétoprrojecteur
pour aller le brancher sur un mur. Euh
voilà, si on se pose j'arrive, paf, j'ai
l'ordi qui marche, je mets ma clé USB
dedans, je file un cours. Ensuite,
est-ce qu'il y a un problème avec
science ? Je pense et je dis pas ça pour
cracher dans la soupe. J'ai profité de
ce système. J'ai fait une classe
préparatoire en France et j'ai fait une
grande école en France. Je pense qu'en
France, on a un problème avec les
classes préparatoires, on a un problème
avec les grandes écoles vraiment parce
qu'on dépense cin ou six fois plus pour
les étudiants dans les classes
préparatoires et dans les grandes écoles
que pour les étudiants à la fac. Il se
trouve qu'en plus sociologiquement les
étudiants à la facilieux
plus défavorisés. Donc en France, on est
dans un système éducatif où on dépense
plus d'argent public
pour les enfants de riches que pour les
enfants de pauvres. Je pense qu'il faut
augmenter fondamentalement les moyens de
l'université et je pense que aujourd'hui
pour augmenter les moyens de
l'université, il faut rapprocher les
universités des grandes écoles. Il faut
refusionner les universités avec les
classes préparatoires. C'est
indispensable. On peut pas laisser
aujourd'hui notre jeunesse euh
avoir aussi peu accès à des conditions
d'enseignement qui sont des conditions
d'enseignement digne. C'est pas normal
aujourd'hui d'arriver dans un amphi et
de devoir vous asseoir par terre. C'est
pas normal. Et ça c'est vrai que les
grandes écoles y compris Science Po
elles ont leur part de responsabilité
euh parce qu'elles tirent à ell une
partie des ressources qui correspond pas
à la réalité de leur nombre d'étudiants
par rapport à tous les autres étudiants
qui sont à l'université. Vous voulez
rajouter un mot sur le grand reset ou
pas du tout ?
Sur grand reset ? Bah non.
Alors, est-ce que vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ?
Bah, mobilisez-vous, engagez-vous,
comment ?
Faites de la politique,
allez dans la Non, non, mais si, mais
pour de vrai, mais attendez,
franchement, vous soufflez. Il y a pas
que de la politique, faut pas faire que
de la politique. Il faut faire des
mouvements, il faut aller dans la rue,
il faut manifester autrement,
il faut créer de l'emploi, il faut
protéger ses salariés,
il faut faire de la politique. Comment
vous changez les règles du jeu si vous
faites pas de politique ? Comment vous
changez les règles du jeu s'il y a que
des gens qui ont fait l'ENAT ? Finance
PO et l'inspection générale des finances
qui nous gouverne. Comment vous changez
ces règles du jeu là ? Ouais, il faut
aussi créer de l'emploi. Il y a des gens
qui créent de l'emploi et heureusement
tout le monde n'est pas là pour faire de
la politique. Mais il faut aussi que les
jeunes s'engagent en politique. Il faut
que les jeunes s'engagent aussi en
créant des médias et en finançant ces
médias là. Il faut un il faut il faut
croire à la possibilité de changer les
choses. Euh je moi je je crois
fondamentalement qu'on peut encore
changer les choses. Il y a il y a plein
de gens qui ont complètement renoncé,
hein.
Il faut infiltrer pour faire exploser.
Ouais.
Moi, je suis assez d'accord avec Geofre
de la gagnerie là-dedans. D'une certaine
manière, faut faire changer les choses
de l'intérieur.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ouais.
Euh
j'ai le bouquin d'une philosophe que
j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Barbara
Stigler. Le bouquin s'appelle Il faut
s'adapter. Euh dans ce livre-là, elle
repense tout un duel euh de philosophes
états-uniens, John Deay et Walter
Lipman. Et je trouve que que ce qu'elle
dit euh de la théorie de l'expertise euh
de Walter Lipman nous apprend beaucoup
euh sur ce que fait Emmanuel Macron euh
aujourd'hui. Euh je pense que c'est un
bouquin indispensable et euh je le
conseille fondamentalement à toute votre
communauté. Ça c'est le premier livre.
Euh le deuxième bouquin à conseiller,
bah j'essaie de de de penser dans euh
dans des champs différents. Faut je
conseille que des bouquins en sciences
sociales, en science politique ou un peu
de littérature, je sais pas. Euh
qu'est-ce que j'ai qu'est-ce que j'ai lu
en dernier ? Je suis en train de de me
demander ce que j'ai lu et ce que j'ai
vraiment aimé. Euh dans les derniers
bouquins que j'ai lu et que j'ai
vraiment aimé, je vais peut-être vous
étonner. Je pense que vous allez bondir
mais je pense qu'on apprend beaucoup
aussi. J'ai relu tout l'intégral d'Ana
Arent. Alors non non vous rigolez parce
que Anna Harent, on la voit souvent
comme une philosophe ultra conservatrice
et c'est pas faux. C'est exactement la
perception que j'avais d'Ana Arent comme
quelqu'un d'ultra conservateur. Et si
vous lisez les dernières écrits d'Ana
Arent, c'est de facto une philosophe qui
est ultra conservatrice. Pourquoi ? Ça
s'explique en grande partie par le fait
qu'elle part d'Allemagne pour aller
vivre aux États-Unis, qu'aux États-Unis,
elle est baignée dans l'université
américaine et qu'elle se construit
entièrement. elle construit toute sa
pensée finalement fondamentalement euh
autour de la question de la guerre
froide. Et en plus ce qui est
complètement fou he c'est que Har écrit
dans les années 50 par exemple, elle
parle jamais de la question noire et des
discriminations raciales aux États-Unis.
Mais si vous lisez la Anna Arent du
début et c'est vraiment ce que j'ai
fait, j'ai j'ai relu tout ce qu'avait
écrit Anna Arent. Si vous lisez vraiment
la Anna Arent du début, de quoi vous
vous rendez compte ? qu'elle met au cœur
de sa pensée politique le fait de donner
à chacun ce qu'elle appelle sa part de
bonheur public, de permettre à chacun de
participer à la vie politique, de
participer au débat public. Il y a une
des phrases qu'elle a écrit, que je cite
dans dans mon livre et qu'elle écrit en
56 où elle dit qu'il faut faire rentrer
les femmes des catégories populaires
dans le débat public. Elle écrit ça en
56. Je pense qu'aujourd'hui en 2020, on
n' toujours pas pensé l'entrée des
femmes et l'entrée des classes
populaires dans le débat politique, dans
le débat public et que ça se voit
fondamentalement quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui l'Assemblée nationale, vous
avez une assemblée nationale où vous
n'avez pas de députés ouvriers, où vous
n'avez quasiment pas de députés employés
et ça c'est un véritable problème
démocratique. Ça Arent en parle, elle le
documente et ça m'a vachement donné à
penser
le fait de la relire.
Voilà, je vais vous parler, je vais vous
dire quand même un roman. C'est un de
mes romanciers préférés, c'est un
romancier états-unien qui s'appelle Paul
Ster et un de ses derniers romans, ça
s'appelle 4321. Euh c'est un roman qui
m'a vachement marqué, beaucoup frappé
parce que c'est un roman en fait
s'appelle 4321 qui raconte quatre fois
la même histoire euh mais pas de la même
manière parce qu'il y a un passage dans
l'histoire à chaque fois qui change et
qui fait que l'avenir du héros va se
modifier complètement euh en fonction de
finalement un petit choc, un petit
moment historique. Euh et ça nous dit
beaucoup sur notre fragilité en tant que
humain, sur notre précarité en tant en
tant qu'humain et sur le fait que tout
euh ne tient qu'à un fil. Euh donc je me
dis que de temps en temps aussi ça vaut
le coup de de lire des romans simplement
pour le plaisir de lire des romans. Euh
de lire des romans euh sans faire de
politique. Et celui-là, je le conseille
vraiment.
Vous connaissiez la chaîne YouTube ?
Ouais.
C'était quoi votre vidéo préférée ?
Ah, j'en ai regardé un j'en ai regardé
un paquet. Il y a il y en a que je
m'attendais pas à voir euh chez vous par
exemple. Euh il y avait Anlor Kisher qui
était là il y a pas longtemps. Je dis
tiens mais pourquoi pas ? On fait de la
finance. J'avais regardé Mondbourg,
j'avais regardé bah Joufroid de la
gagnerie parce que j'aime bien ce qu'il
fait aussi. Je crois que la G il est
jamais passé chez nous.
Vous avez pas fait chez vous ? Bah du
coup, j'avais pas regardé mais j'aime
bien quand même son dernier bouquin
parce que vous me demandez une
recommandation de livre. Pourquoi je
l'ai imaginé chez vous ? Peut-être parce
que vous devez l'inviter. Alors
peut-être parce que je vous ai vu taguer
sur Twitter. Les gens on dit il faut
inviter KG Julia
et Geoffre la gagnerie
et du coup vous l'avez pas fait.
Julia Kagé. Merci.
Merci.
[Musique]